Musique Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Hey, da sind wir wieder. Das ist das Intro, was wir gewählt haben, um aus der Sommerpause zurückzukommen.
Yannick, vielen Dank für das fantastische Intro.
Yannick, du hast dir Mühe gegeben, ich fand's toll.
Aber nochmal auch von uns beiden, ihr müsst uns keine Intro, also es ist nicht jeder von euch muss, wir dachten eher so, die Leute, die mal irgendwie ein Instrument schon bei der Hand hatten in dem Leben, die können uns gerne ein Intro schicken. Ich glaube, viele haben das falsch verstanden, viele fühlen sich gezwungen und haben ein schlechtes Gewissen, wenn sie keine Intro einsenden. Müsst ihr nicht, legt die Stöcke wieder hin, den Dirigierstab, lasst ihn gerne in der Schublade, muss nicht sein. Nein, Yannick, fantastisch. Vielen Dank. Y-N-N-P-H.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich mir trotzdem ein bisschen was, also nichts gegen, aber es war eher so ein Winter-Intro. Ich hätte mir eher was, also dafür, dass wir auf dem Sommerschlaf gerade kommen, hätte ich mir ein bisschen was Spritzigeres gewünscht, so ab in den Südenartats. Funic?
Wie war dein Sommer?
Ja, der war heiß, war so heiß, heiß, ich schwitze, war so heiß, ist es heiß, es ist tatsächlich sehr heiß, aber da haben wir gar nicht drüber gesprochen, weil wir in der Sommerpause waren, wir haben uns ein bisschen zurückgelegt, wir waren am Beach, wir haben ein bisschen gesagt, einfach mal einen Standardsommer, mal so einen richtigen generischen Sommer, mal Beachbar, Coco Beach, einfach mal einen schönen, irgendwie so dieser Stroh-Röcke angezogen und einfach mal Sommer-Sommer sein lassen. Spikeball spielen. Ja, nicht immer diese ironische Brechung, nicht immer doppelt um die Ecke, nee, einfach mal mit richtig Sonnencreme am Strand liegen. Nee, ein Eins-zu-eins-Sonnen. So einen wollte ich auch mal haben. Ich habe wirklich mit Freunden, Bekannten im Park Spikeball gespielt. Hast du bestimmt schon mal gesehen, hast dich auch gefragt, wie ich, was ist das für ein Spiel mit dem Trampolin und dem Ball. Da steht man dann drum im Kreis und ja, exakt, wo man aber auch, nee, aber genau diese Art, die hält dich von einem Eins-zu-eins-Sommer. Richtig, ja. Ein On-the-Nose-Sommer. Ja, ja. Und ich hab den nämlich, ich hab mal abgelegt mein Och und mein, oh, natürlich machen sie das, sondern hab mal einfach den Ball in die Hand, den schlecht aufgepumpten Ball in die Hand genommen und hab Spikeball schlecht gespielt. Wurde dann fertig gemacht von meinem Teamkameraden und bin dann um 22 Uhr nach Hause. Das ist nämlich dieser 1 zu 1 Sommer, den wir doch alle so lieben. Ist doch herrlich. Am nächsten Tag zum See, Zeckel geholt. Schön sehen, schönes Bumbum am Kiosk, irgendwie fällt es runter, herrlich. So lieben wir dort den Sommer. Wir waren jetzt, wir drehen ja fleissig, also von wegen entspannter Sommer, wir drehen ja fleissig Staffel drei und wir waren alle im Wald, haben dann eine Waldszene aufgenommen. Simpsons oder? Staffel drei? Richtig, wir drehen Staffel drei Simpsons und wir hatten alle Zecken. Ja? Wir hatten alle, jeder hatte eine Zecke. Und das ist auch wirklich, wenn man zwei Leute kontrolliert, so mal aus Spass und mal gucken, ob man eine Zecke hat und alle haben dann so einen rot angeschwollenen, schwarzen Punkt an sich dran, denkt man auch, holy shit. Zecken kommen von unten, ne? Ja, also Urban Myth, sie kommen von oben. Ja, Wahrheit, sie kommt, stellt sich raus, kommt von unten. Sie kommt von unten, Country Myth, sie kommen von unten. Man denkt, man fühlt sich immer so sicher, wenn man da mit Regenschirm und Hut bewährt irgendwie in den Dschungel geht. Nein, die kommen von unten, die laufen an dich ran, schweben, so ein bisschen wie Luke Skywalker, der unten an den 80-80 sich mit seiner Harpune ranhakt und ranzieht. Die haben sowas ähnliches wie Harpune. Ich glaube, die haben wie so Spider-Man, so diese Fähdenschüsse. Wie Spider-Man, statt wie Spinne zu sagen, geht ein bisschen über den komischen Umweg. Weiss man, wer zuerst da war, Spider oder Spider-Man? Ich weiss es gar nicht genau. Spider-Schwein. Und ich habe nur mal gehört, dass, ich habe mich mal über Zecken informiert, weil ich selber einen hatte, und da habe ich gehört, man soll nach jedem Waldspaziergang, soll man nach Hause gehen, den Spiegel von der Wand nehmen, auf den Boden legen, sich nackt ausziehen und sich nackt auf dem Spiegel räkeln. Das stand in so einem Geolino-Naturkunde-Ding. Das ganze Filmen und an Norbert Geolino, Edgermichs, die schicken. Aber bitte nicht über drei Megabyte. Und nicht, wenn ihr älter als 20 seid. Und das sollte man jedes Mal machen. Und da dachte ich mir wirklich, sorry, nichts gegen Natur, aber du fällst immer weiter im Kurs.
Ich kann jetzt nicht nach jedem Waldspaziergang, mich nackt auf, also wirklich traumatischer geht es ja kaum, sich nackt auf einem Spiegel zu räkeln, um seinen Körper machen zu stehen. Ich finde, alles, was mit dem Wort Räkeln verbunden ist, sollte man lassen. Jetzt mal eine sehr private Frage, hast du dich schon mal geräkelt? Äh, also jetzt, also ich dachte, bis gerade räkeln wäre auch sowas wie im Bett noch mal morgens eine Umdrehung wagen. Und dann so räkelt man sich. Ich habe auch so eine Strecken-Assoziation im Kopf. Bin ich da jetzt ganz falsch weg oder so? Oder ist schon räkeln? Ich weiß es nicht genau, ich weiß nicht. Ich habe mich auf jeden Fall schon mal geräkelt. Es ist jetzt natürlich schwer für unsere französischen Austauschhörer, die jetzt gerade diese Folge hören und sich denken, oh, Rekkel, Kis, Kis, Kis, die nicht genau wissen, was da los ist. Es ist immer wieder versucht, wir haben keine französischen Austauschhörer. Naja, ein paar schon. Pierre ist da, ansonsten, ja, er ist still. Er ist still geworden in Frankreich. Hat mal jemand geguckt, was da gerade los ist? Das Gefühl, dass man vielleicht so ein Land vergessen hat, jetzt auch durch diese ganze Corona-Kram, niemand reist mehr, alle hängen in ihrem Land ab, in ihrem eigenen Haus. Hat mal jemand nach zum Beispiel Moldawien? Was geht da gerade ab? Kann mal irgendjemand kurz rüberschauen und einfach mal kurz Deckel auf, reingucken, alles in Ordnung, alles cool bei euch, ja passt, okay cool. Wenn sie alle umdrehen, nee, alles gut, dann weiss man, ist vielleicht was im Argen in Moldawien. Wenn man in den Raum geht und es wird still. Und ihr so, redet ruhig weiter. Nö, nö, nö. No, no, no, si claro. Oder welche Sprache immer die verspricht. Naja, ich sag mal so, ich will jetzt nicht die Stimmung zu sehr runterziehen, aber der alles fressende Heuschreckenschwarm in Nord- und Westafrika gibt es immer noch. Also hat sich nichts an der Situation geändert. Kann man gerne mal sich drum kümmern, falls jemand Bock hat. Zeit und Bock irgendwie darüber mit einer Fliegenklatsche. Nee, aber da... So eine elektrische vielleicht. Den Leuten geht es sehr schlecht, mit denen alles weggefressen wird. Elektrische Fliegenklatschen für Afrika. Die haben nichts mehr zu essen. Alles, was die sich in ihren Mund schieben wollen, wird, bevor sie den Gaumen erreichen, von Heuschrecken aufgefressen. Du hast eine ganz andere Stimme. Ja, meine Stimme verändert sich. Es ist ganz merkwürdig. Ich habe das in letzter Zeit gemerkt, meine Stimme verändert sich. Ich habe tatsächlich gegoogelt, ich habe ohne Witz gegoogelt, zweiter Stimmbruch. Ich wusste nicht, kann ja sein, dass es mehrere gibt. Du hast eine ganz andere Stimme. Ich habe dich seit Monaten nicht gesprochen. Ja, irgendwie, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, woher das kommt. Die ist voluminöser. Ich glaube, ich bin auch... Oh, okay, dann redet weiter. Kräftiger, ein bisschen männlicher, oder was? Nee, ein bisschen quietschig. Voluminös und quietschig. Ja, es ist schwer zu beschreiben. Voluminös unten. Nee, so als hättest du so ein ganz... Du müsstest mal ganz doll husten. Ja, nee, es kann schon sein, dass ich todkrank bin. Aber ich habe auch gegoogelt zweiter Stimmbruch und widersprüchliche Informationen gefunden. Also gute Frage hat das anders beantwortet als Wikipedia. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich mich verorten soll. Aber hoffst du, dass er jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Wartungsbekommen, Peniswachstum einsetzt? So eine zweite Pubertät eigentlich. Ich bin ganz ehrlich, meine Brustbehaarung lässt zu Wunsch übrig. Also es ist nicht so, ich habe letztens mit jemandem gesprochen, der meinte, Alter, ich muss mir echt alle zwei Wochen den Rücken rasieren. Und ich so, ja, alter, mega nervig. Das ist der Schlimmste. Mega nervig. Es ist natürlich nervig, aber man fühlt sich in der Männlichkeit schon angegriffen, weil man sich denkt so, warum nicht ich? Warum nicht ich? Also vielleicht gibt es noch eine zweite Pubertät, wie so zweiter Frühling oder so, ich weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet, aber klingt okay, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall wissenschaftlich nicht klar festgelegt, ob es einen zweiten Stimmbruch gibt. Aber auch gut, dass man ein paar Wochen nicht aufnimmt und alle Hörer so Spaß machen, oh, danach verändert sich alles und ja, der eine hat eine ganz neue Stimme. Ich versuche langsam den Ausstieg zu schaffen vom Podcast-Ufo.
Das heißt, ich versuche meine Stimme langsam, aber sicher in Richtung Donny zu schaffen, um eines Tages absteigen zu können. Wohingegen Donny versucht immer mehr in Richtung mir zu gehen. Das wäre mir ganz egal. Hauptsache, ich sitze wieder mit jemandem, der so klingt. Ehrlich gesagt bin ich gerade ein bisschen nostalgisch. Ja? Ja, aber deine alte Stimme hat mir gefallen. Ich weiß nicht, warum du die jetzt ändern musst. So, ich weiss nicht, ob sie zurückkommt. Man kann ja tatsächlich, einige haben jetzt geschrieben während der Sommerpause, dass wir nochmal von vorne angefangen haben, Podcast UFO. Und die Corona-Witz ist sehr schlecht gealtert, habe ich auch gehört. Sehr schlecht gealtert. Und meine Stimme wiegt einfach 50 Kilo mehr. Was man hört, also das ist jetzt schon die zweite Änderung meiner Stimme innerhalb dieses Podcast-Projekts. Wohin ging du immer noch jugendlich spritzige 17 Jahre. Ich rede immer gleich, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich war damals eloquenter. Weil irgendwer hat eine alte Folge zitiert, da habe ich da mal reingehört und dachte mir, what, dieses Wort habe ich noch nie mehr gehört, dachte ich, wenn ich es nicht wäre, der da spricht. Ja, das war während deinem Spiritualismus-Studium, wo du einfach jeden Tag Input auf hohem intellektuellen Niveau bekommen hast und mittlerweile nur noch irgendwie Buffet, Catering. Nee, ohne Scheiß, ich dachte, ich bin wie so ein Kind, weil ich habe auch zum Beispiel jetzt Nachbarskinder, kleine, und eins von denen hat dann so, ich bin dann mit dem Fahrrad los und habe dann das Kind gegrüsst und das Kind gesagt, hallo, Stefan, deine Kette ist raus. Ja, hallo, hey, alles gut, ist aber auch niemand. Und das Kind hat gesagt, hallo, Stefan, du bist ein bisschen wie das Sixten-Sense-Kind. Ich dachte gleich, hinter dir steht ein Toner Mensch. Nein, deine Kette ist raus. Und dann ist sie hochgegangen, die Treppe hochgeschwebt. Und ich dachte mir, what? Hab geguckt, tatsächlich meine Kette war raus, ich wollte die Leute einfach so losgefahren, hab nicht gesehen, dass meine Kette raus ist, habe dann mit den Eltern drüber gesprochen, später, unabhängig davon, und habe das gesagt, was ich so lustig fand im Moment, und dann meinten die, ja, der hat auch gerade von ihm, Kumpel von ihm war die Kette raus, und Kinder reagieren halt, wenn sie so etwas gerade erlebt haben in ihrem Leben, scannen sie ihr Leben danach ab, und das ganze Mind ist auf Kette rausgesprägt. Ja, verstehe. Deswegen fällst du dann halt auf, weil der darauf jetzt achtet. Und ich bin genauso, weil ich hatte dann damals Journalismusstudium, hab dann ein paar Wörter aufgeschnappt und dann rede ich die ganze Zeit von diesen Wörtern. Weil ich bin ähnlich, ich bin durchlässig wie ein Kind, glaube ich. Man kann Sachen in mich reinstecken, in den Filter und dann kommen sie direkt wieder raus. Du bist so wie bei den Sims, die dann immer so einen Zustand haben. Zustand verwirrt. Und dann sind die halt einfach, das ist so ganz eindimensional. Ja, ich bin wie so eine Sims oder wie so eine Sitcom-Figur. Ja, hat gerade Wort gelernt, Defettismus und jetzt überall guckt man. Ja genau und wenn Leute den ganzen Tag bei mir verbringen, sind die auch sehr schnell genervt, weil ich mich wiederhole andauernd. Und jetzt mittlerweile bin ich in meinem eindimensionalen Leben gefangen und spreche nicht mehr so schlau und eloquent wie damals. Ich finde dich immer noch sehr eloquent. Du bist vielleicht auch wieder ein bisschen bodenständiger geworden. Vielleicht. Du bist nicht mit der abgehobene Elfenbein-Stefan, für die du auch kritisiert wurdest. Der kann Stefan. Natürlich ist er immer kurz, er ist ja auch wie ein Kind plötzlich, was dann verwöhnt ist und Hummer gegessen hat an der Kutazur. Da bist du halt auch nicht der Kellerwohnung, der Deutschstefan. Nein, du kannst nicht vor einem riesigen Tisch voller Shrimps stehen und nicht ein anderer Mensch werden. Das geht nicht. Ja, das ist völlig richtig. Ich bin gespannt, was noch passiert mit der Stimme. Ich auch, wie gesagt, ich finde eigentlich das Konzept, ja, ich finde das Konzept ja auch interessant, so von so einer zweiten Jugend, also auch so, wer sagt denn, dass es nicht nochmal sowas wie Milchzähne gibt, also dass man irgendwie einfach mit 40 nochmal alle Zähne verliert. Wie Haie, Haie verlieren ständig Zähne, die machen andauernd nach, wie Fingernehrger. Ja, alle 20 Minuten zack zack hauen die die Zähne raus. Es ist furchtbar. Aber ich habe ja tatsächlich, weil ich so ein bisschen gekämpft habe mit dem Thema Mundgeruch tatsächlich und dann war ich beim Arzt, Hals, Nasen, Ohren Arzt, wo man sich auch überlegt, soll man zu der Zeit jetzt gerade zum Hals, Nasen, Ohren geht es, haben die nicht gerade anderes zu tun? Aber auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich, vielleicht haben die auch mal Bock auf ein bisschen Abwechslung. Ja, Corona hast, gehst du zum Hals und Ohrenarzt, oder? Ja, vor allem, ich glaube auch so bei der Pest, da dachte jeder Arzt so, geil, ich bin jetzt der krasse Arzt, ich heile alle. Nach zwei Wochen denkst du dir, oh komm, dir mal wieder ein so ein, irgendwie so ein Bein ab oder sowas. Hast du auch Bock mal wieder zu machen, einfach ein bisschen Cholera wieder mit reinzukriegen. kriegen. Und deswegen dachte ich, ich gehe zum Arzt und die meinte dann auch so, ja, sie haben eine Mandelentzündung, irgendwie alles kaputt und so. Deswegen kann es schon sein, dass es da noch irgendwie Nachwirkungen sind davon. Aber ja, Mundgeruch ist aber gut, dass man da, ich finde es so gut, wie offen man damit umgeht. Ja, es ist sehr stigmatisiert. Total, aber es ist auch wichtig, Leute darauf hinzuweisen, dass sie Mundgeruch haben. Eben, weil das ist mir das Problem, weil es wird nicht hingewiesen drauf, natürlich nicht. Und vor allem, du riechst es auch erst, sobald dich jemand darauf hinweist. Klar, kann natürlich eine Paranoia führen, weil du nicht ganz objektiv sagen kannst, ob du Mundgeruch hast oder nicht. Mit den Masken kriegt man es natürlich mit, weil du natürlich die ganze Zeit in deine Nase atmest. Das ist auch nicht so. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich auch so. Eigentlich kriegt man es nicht. Ja genau, bei mir war es nämlich auch so, erst nachdem mir jemand gesagt hat, hey, alles okay, habe ich das gerochen. Und ich habe dann auch recherchiert und habe so ein paar, ja so ein paar Dog Whistles mitbekommen, wie Leute jemanden normalerweise sagen, weil da hieß es dann nämlich auch, schlechter Mundgeruch kann oft was mit Magen zu tun haben, dass irgendwie Gerüche aus dem Magen wieder durch den Mund kommen. Also fragen die dich, hast du vielleicht einen Magen zu hören? Genau, also fragen die dich, ist alles okay mit deinem Magen? Und du denkst, das ist die spezifische Frage der ganzen Welt, aber wie kommt es auf meinen Magen? Genau, also falls ihr mal gefragt wurdet, ob mit eurem Magen alles okay ist, rückwirkend solltet ihr jetzt realisieren, dass jemand euch darauf hinweisen wollte, dass ihr fucking Mundgeruch habt. Ja, realisiert spätestens jetzt, dass diese Frage aus einem ganz komischen Grund gestellt wurde. Ja, und deswegen habe ich da so ein bisschen recherchiert. Aber ich bin natürlich auch in die sehr unangenehme Sphäre der Mandelsteine eingestiegen. Googelt es nicht, tut euch das nicht an, es ist furchtbar. Und ich habe da ein bisschen experimentiert damit, weil es gibt so in den Mandeln, können sich so Ablagerungen verhärten und dann so so weissen Steinchen werden. Und da gibt es im Internet... Wie kann man dann sammeln und tauschen? Nee, kann man tatsächlich sammeln und tauschen. Es gibt im Internet eine ganze Branche von Pinzetten und Sachen und Utensilien, wie man die raustun kann. Alles furchtbar, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Und ich habe dann die ganze Zeit, ich habe dann gegen meinen Würgereflex angearbeitet, weil wenn du dir gegen die Mandeln drückst, musst du ja würgen. Und deswegen habe ich aktiv versucht, mir den abzugewöhnen und habe da halt immer rumgedrückt. Und dann war ich bei der Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Äztin, die meinte, ja, das ist alles rot angeschwollen bei Ihnen da. Und ich dachte mir, kann damit zusammenhängen, dass ich seit zwei Wochen da versuche, meinen Rachen rauszuoperieren. Und die meine, nee, Mandeln entzündete, ja, die wird das schon wissen. Und das ist so geil, die meinte dann auch so, ja, ich meine, zur Not müsste man die Mandeln halt auch rausnehmen, das könnte mein Mann machen. Hä? Was? Okay. Das könnte ihr Mann machen? Ist der Arzt? Das habe ich nicht gefragt, aber das war so ... Okay, also ... Mandeln. Auf eine Art macht Sinn. Mandeln, meinst du? Nee, aber ... Wegen Mann, oder was? Das kann meine Tochter, mein Cousin machen. Hä? Ganz merkwürdig. Nee, ich will nicht in ihr Familienbusiness einsteigen. Ja, wirklich so einfach so dieser Familienclan. Irgendwie so, da kann sich mein Mann drum kümmern. Mandelmaul. Dann gehe ich auf einen Mann mit so einer Heckenschere. Einfach so, ich mache das schon. Ganz merkwürdig, ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Und dann ein neuer Arzt. Zweitmeinung, die beliebte Zweitmeinung. Aber ist es... Aber ist es... Nee, habe ich nicht... Ist es Zweitmeinungsgein? Null, überhaupt nicht. Ich bin 0,5 Meinung. Ich bin schon beim ersten Anzeichen, bin ich schon überzeugt. Nee, ich bin meistens, ich will gar nicht erst zum Arzt, geschweige denn, ich gehe zweimal zum Arzt, wegen der gleichen Sache. Ich habe eh schon immer dieses Syndrom, wie man das nennt, das Gegenteil von, ähm... Hyboronder? Hyboronder, weil wenn ich im Warteraum sitze, bin ich sehr fest in Überzeugung, ich habe gar nichts. Ja. Impostorsyndrom dann eher. Ich bin hier gerade... Oh, da gibt es bestimmte Begriffe. Dann fangen die alle an zu husten nebenan im Warteraum und haben so offensichtlich Probleme, fassen sich ans Knie, Blut, Blut und da halt. Ja, Pfeil im Kopf und du fühlst dich schlecht. Ja, und weil ich dann so einen Ausschlag denke zu haben, gucke ich mir die Hand an, weg, Ausschlag ist weg. Ja, und man reibt dann noch so über den Stuhl und denkt sich, scheiße, komm, der war noch da, der war noch da, wie man einem Handwerker zeigt, zum Problem führt und dann geht Wasserhahn. Dass man nochmal dagegen tritt oder so, dass es möglichst kaputt aussieht. So fühlt man mich davor in meinem Warteraum und dann denke ich mir, komm, jetzt noch einmal dieses Schwörmchen über den grauen Draht bewegen, in der Ecke, da ist ein Spielding und dann nach Hause gehen. Und er so, und Herr Tietze, was fehlt Ihnen? Wissen Sie, auf dem Weg von mir zu Hause hierher haben sich sämtliche Symptome aufgelöst. Von daher, ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag. Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag, auch grüssen Sie Ihren Mann. Genau. Mein Mann kann Sie nach Hause fahren. Wirklich? Okay. Warum nicht? Ja es kann natürlich auch sein, dass es ein Ehepaar ist, wo beide Hals, Nasen, Ohren Arzt sind. Wie ist das generell beliebt? Häufig, dass Partner, die den exakt selber, nicht den exakt selber. Medizinpaare sind beliebt. Na ja gut, aber da ist dann einer Fussarzt und der andere Handarzt oder so. Alle Freunde, die ich habe, die Medizin studieren, haben alle Medizineltern. Und zwar beide. Aber dann auch dieselbe Art Arzt? Meistens ja. Wirklich? Meistens ja. Aber dann nicht zusammen eine Praxis oder so, dass du dann zwei Gynäkologen zusammen eine Praxis hast irgendwie. Nee, das ist dann nicht. Aber es ist schon wirklich, also ich glaube, wenn ihr wirklich unglücklich Single seid, studiert Medizin oder Pädagogik, also so Lehramt, ist auch immer Lehrer, Ehepaare, unfassbar beliebt, immer unfassbar unsympathisch und immer schwierige Kinder, entweder die in Richtung Kunst streben oder auf der Strasse landen. Und man wird ja wirklich unglücklich gesagt, studiert Medizin, weil da findet ihr auf jeden Fall den Partner eines Lebens. Und ihr werdet ein Kind haben, was auch Mediziner wird. Also so im Prinzip Win-Win-Win-Situation. Ist eigentlich perfekt, aber ist natürlich auch gut wegen Urlaub. Als Lehrer Urlaub hast du dann genau gleich Urlaub, kann natürlich auch schlecht sein.
Ja, aber auch dann Urlaub, wenn alle Urlaub haben. Ja, okay, gut, gut, kann schon schlecht sein, ja. Aber vor allem im Wartezimmer von dieser HNO-Äztin, in dem Wartezimmer, gibt es ja so Wartezimmerliteratur, halt dann so die Bunte oder sowas. Ja, Literatur ist Euphemismus des Jahres. Ja, obwohl ich mir immer denke, das interessiert mich nicht.
Man blättert da natürlich schon manchmal drin, aber da stand auch hinter einem Regal mit einer Glastür so wirklich so 16 bändig der menschliche Körper, so 16 tiefrote Bände. Und ich dachte mir, darf ich jetzt diese Vitrine aufschieben und einfach mal bei A anfangen, einfach mal wirklich so A, A los. Und dann Und dann, Herr Will, ich bin noch nicht durch. Ich bin noch, sorry, ich bin noch bei A, ganz kurz. Aber ich habe mich nicht getraut, einfach mal so. Bei D. Wie lange sitzen Sie hier denn schon? Daumen, Däumling, Däumchen, Däumchen, kleiner siehe Daumen. Bl, Blätter, Blätter, Blätter. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber wenn ich in einem Sprechzimmer bin mit dem Arzt, es ist generell auch seltsam, dass man erst im Wartezimmer sitzt, dann nochmal ins Sprechzimmer gerufen wird, dann auch nochmal wartet. Das sind so die vier Stationen, die man durchlaufen muss. Weil ist es da um das Wartezimmer? Frage an euch. Ist es dafür da, dass man das Wartezimmer entlastet, die Kapazität runterschraubt, damit es nicht zu voll wird? Ich werde aber auch aus leeren Wartezimmer in das Sprechzimmer gesetzt, wo ich noch alleine eine halbe Stunde auf den Arzt warte. Und dann kommt der da. Warum dieser Zwischenschritt? Warum diese Platzverlagerung? Ohne, dass man dann den Guardian lesen kann oder Forbes. Ja, stimmt schon. Ja, ich glaube, einer ist schwierig. Das finde ich wirklich ganz selten. Das können bestimmt Leute beantworten. Schreibt es in die Kommentare, bitte. Und warum braucht man denn Liene? Ja, eins nach dem anderen. Tatsächlich, als ich meinen gebrochenen C hatte, ich bei so einem, ja scheiße, vier falsche Wörter, das ist mir gleichzeitig eingefallen. Nicht Paläontologe. Du warst ganz wunderbar. Pediatrician, aber Pedant. Pedast? Pedant. Ich war bei so einem Pedanten. Und da gab es sogar drei Stufen. Da gab es Wartezimmer und dann noch zwei weitere Sitzstationen, bevor man im Behandlungszimmer war. Ja, weil die ersten mal die Fälle, weil die beobachten nicht mehr, wie du da hingehst, um zu gucken, ob er nicht irgendwie wirklich wie ich dann nichts hat, obwohl er dann da beim Arzt sitzt. Ja, ja, genau. Er muss dann so einem grossen Spiegel vorbei, wo der Pedant dann daneben sitzt und guckt, wie du läufst. Worauf ich noch was wollte. Wie geht es dir denn, wenn du im Sprechzimmer bist und der Arzt sitzt dir gegenüber und hinter ihm sind sämtliche Bücher über das Fach, wo er seine Doktorarbeit praktiziert. Weil ich denke immer, zum einen weird, wenn er sie nicht hätte, weil hat man ja als Arzt genau wie diese Auszeichnungen und Fortbildungszertifikat an der Wand. Also irgendwie, man ist beruhigt, weil man, weil es ein generischer Arzt ist. Auf der anderen Seite, muss er dann nachgucken dann manchmal? Warum hat er diese Bücher überhaupt in the first place? Lernt man denn noch damit oder lernt man nicht eher mit dem Internet oder
will man denn so einen Arzt, der darauf
theoretisch zugreifen muss?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber
ich glaube, es ist schon manchmal so, dass man sagt,
ich habe da so ein Ziehen im Knie,
oh fuck, und er denkt sich, scheiße, Knie habe ich
komplett durchgesoffen, das
Kniesemester habe ich komplett
versoffen.
Welche Art von Ziehen und dann einfach so unterm Tisch so K-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k-k ist besser, weil willst du denn in den Arzt gehen, wo im Sprechzimmer einfach irgendwie so 16 mal Argo steht oder so im Regal hinten oder so ein lustiges Taschenbuch.
Ich glaube, du hast nicht viel Optionen, da irgendwie medizinische Bücher hinzutun.
Ich fände es ja okay, dass ein Arzt, ich finde es immer gut, wenn man Bescheidenheit zeigt und einfach man sagt so,
wissen Sie was, Herr Titzer, jetzt haben Sie mich, ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, was Ihnen fehlen könnte,
aber ich habe hier dieses große Buch, lass uns mal zusammen reingucken. Ja, und der sieht mich auf den Schoss und dann zeigt mir dann das Kapitel. Guck mal hier, das ist ein Arm, das ist das Herz. Dann zeigt mir der Pederast, bei dem ich auf dem Schoss sitze, zeigt mir dann das richtige Kapitel. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ich war lange nicht mehr beim Arzt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, ich habe keinen Krankheitstag in meiner gesamten Arbeitshistorie und in meiner ganzen Schulzeit auch keinen Krankheitstag. Nee, krank auch nicht. Warum nicht? Ich weiß es nicht. Es sind Menschen, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe, die es auch haben. Ich glaube, das Leben ist ja wie so ein Dominoeffekt, weil wenn du nicht krank bist, denkst du, ich bin nie krank. Und deswegen, sobald du eine Krankheit anklopft, man spiralt sich da rein. Genau, bist du im Placebo und denkst dir, ich bin ja nicht krank, ich bin nie krank. Sagt Mr. Mandel und Zündung. Aber ich gehe trotzdem zur Arbeit, ich huste dich trotzdem an. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen und wohingegen Leute, die ständig krank sind, da ist es dann eher andersrum, dass sie dann eher notsebomässig ständig krank werden und ihr Körper sagt, oh, schon wieder, jetzt geht's los. So, und ich glaube, das ist einfach so, ob du bis zum zehnten Alter, zehnten Lebensjahr einmal hart krank gewesen bist oder nicht, entscheidet dein Rest deines Lebens, ob du ständig krank bist oder nie krank bist. Ich glaube, das ist für dich für so eine Entscheidung. Ja, auch wenn du halt zum schlechten Zeitpunkt irgendwie mal krank bist oder so oder dir was Peinliches passiert, ist deine Schulzeit im Arsch, wenn du dann Spitznamen bekommst oder sowas, wenn dir mal einmal was Dummes passiert und dann bleibst du ja der Schwächling, der Loser, weil du das ja einredest und so, dann spiraltest du dich ja auch rein. Guckt einfach, dass ihr nicht auffallt. Nee, guckt einfach, dass ihr nicht irgendwie mit einem Pogo-Stick eine Scheibe kaputt macht, dass ihr nicht Pogo genannt werdet. Oder vielleicht schon. Pogo. Pogo ist ein mega geiler Spitzname. Guckt, dass ihr irgendwie mit einem Skateboard irgendwie in den Kiosk reinfahrt, dass ihr irgendwie Skate-Skiosk zahlt oder irgendwie sowas. Wenn ich eigentlich versucht, aktiv einen coolen Spitznamen zu generieren, ist eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee. Ja, ja, aktiv einen guten Spitznamen. Also erst mal überlegen, abends am Schreibtisch müsst ihr hinsetzen und überlegen, was wäre ein guter Spitznamen für euch und dann aktiv daran arbeiten.
Aber den man auch umsetzen kann, also dann nicht so wie Fanta oder so, der halt nicht hängen bleibt, sondern irgendwie dann irgendwas, wo man keine Ahnung, der hat mal einen Schaf mit zur Schule gebracht. Schafi. Schafinger oder sowas. Schwer zu sagen, ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber ja, mein Sommer war ganz gut eigentlich.
Wart nicht.
Wobei ich bin ein bisschen ... Also Staffel 3 ist herausgekommen, zum Beispiel 2 der Netflix-Serie, was mich sehr gefreut hat. Ich wollte mich nochmal, vielen Dank bei den ganzen Podcast- Lufo-Hörern, die nett geschrieben haben und die das Boosted Board erkannt haben und die sich sehr gefreut haben, die sich natürlich alle durch die Bank mehr Florentin will für Staffel drei wünschen, was mich auch sehr freut. Das freut mich natürlich auch. Aber es ist spannend, wie kurzlebig denn noch mittlerweile die heutige Zeit ist so. Ja, verrückt. Dann ist man kurz für zwei Wochen und ist dann so, ne nicht mal, eine Woche guckt man dann die neue Serie und dann, wie bei mir ja auch, ist es komplett egal und die nächste Serie ist dran. Ja, sie ist auch kurz und wegsnackbar irgendwie. Das ist ja das Problem. Die ist viel zu kurz und viel zu wegsnackbar. Ja, die ist so kurzweilig, dass man die so wegballert. Aber diese Höhe, wie damals Sendungen linear ausgestrahlt wurden, wo du halt jede Woche das hattest als Macher einer Serie, wo du jede Woche eine Folge präsentieren konntest und die wurde besprochen und so. Da wird es natürlich auch in einer viel grösseren Detaildichte wird dann diese Folge besprochen. Bei uns wird ja selten eine Folge besprochen oder sowas. Man sagt dann immer nur, man gibt das Fazit zur ganzen Staffel ab, weil man guckt die so weg, die kommt auf einmal raus so. Auf einmal nimmt es auch gar nicht als Folgen wahr. Also ich glaube, es gibt niemanden, der zwischen jeden Folgen viel Zeit vergehen lässt. Also man guckt ja entweder vier oder alle, ich glaube, ich habe sogar fast die ganze Staffel am Stück angeguckt und ich glaube, die meisten Leute nehmen das ja gar nicht als Folgen wahr. Es ist die Frage, ob dieses Folgenkonzept eh so, ist das überhaupt noch sinnvoll? Kann man nicht einfach sagen, hier sind drei Stunden Unterhaltung, guckst an und hör auf, wenn du willst. Ja, um es zu gliedern halt, ne? Bisschen schon. Und du bleibst ja auch dran wegen der Cliffhanger und der kurzen Bögen. Das stimmt mit dir schon, ja. Das, glaube ich, macht schon was aus. Aber, ja, du hast schon recht, es ist so wegsnackbar und deswegen, ja, ein bisschen seltsam, aber dass man, also ich, da hat danach schon gedacht so, und das war jetzt eineinhalb Jahre, für die du gearbeitet hast. Ja, aber das ist auch ein bisschen deine Schuld, weil es halt so locker flockig wegzusnacken ist. Du, so eine Staffel Ozark, da hänge ich teilweise einen Monat dran, mich da durchzuarbeiten, weil die halt einfach ein bisschen zäher ist irgendwie als bei euch. Da müsstet ihr euch auch in die eigene Nase greifen, dass es zu kurzweilig ist. Mehr machen, viel mehr folgen, viel mehr, dass es einfach ein bisschen länger dauert. Da hat man auch das Gefühl, weil so bei Mad Men oder sowas, da bist du ja wirklich nach so einer, wenn du so drei Staffeln über einen Monat durchgebinght hast, danach vermisst du ja kurz die Charaktere auch wirklich. Ja, total. Du bist ja quasi angefreundet mit denen, du kennst ja deren Macken, deren Gang, deren Eigenheiten, deren Spreche. Aber es gibt so Saftserien und es gibt so Senfserien. So Saft, den trinkt man so weg. Den trinkt man sofort weg. Wohin ging so ein Glas Senf, das kaufst du und das hast du einen Monat, zwei Monate lang im Kühlschrank. Zum Beispiel, ich schaue jetzt gerade The New Pope an. Zweite Staffel von, ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil die zweite Staffel heisst anders als die erste Staffel. Die erste Staffel heisst The Young Pope und die zweite Staffel heisst The New Pope, was merkwürdig ist, weil es ist die gleiche Serie, aber komisch. Na gut, aber die Prämisse hat sich auch geändert. Die Prämisse hat sich natürlich geändert, wenig Überraschung natürlich, es steckt im Titel, aber die Serie ist so schwer zu schauen, erstmal weil natürlich Sky einfach abschaum ist, sorry Sky-Player ist einfach die Hölle und ich weiß auch nicht die... Also ein schlechter Senf, wo dann die Verpackung der Deckel klemmt. Genau, zu scharf, weil das spielt halt alles im Vatikan und mit diesen ganzen Vatikan-Leuten rum und so und die sprechen halt oft auch Italienisch und Sky kriegt es halt hin, dass halt das nicht untertitelt ist, wenn Italienisch sprechen, wenn du es im Originalaust. Und es ist halt einfach furchtbar, weil wenn du kein Italienisch sprichst, musst du halt einfach damit leben, dass du ein Drittel der Serie A nicht verstehst und dir halt einfach extrem dumm dabei vorkommst, wenn du vor deinem Fernseher sitzt und halt so einen kurzen Moment für dich hast, weil du dir denkst, ich verstehe gerade nichts. Und du mitlachst auch so ein bisschen, dann denkst du ... Oh, hm. Ach so, war nicht lustig gemeint. Oh, dramatisch jetzt. Scusi war danke oder entschuldige. Danke oder bitte, noch mal eins von beiden. Aber das ist eine Serie, da hänge ich wirklich seit Monaten dran. Ja? Da melde ich mich nämlich auch dran, dass ich kurz einfach ... Aber ich meine Arroganz behaupte ja, zumindest drei Wörter Italienisch zu sprechen und hab da natürlich nicht wahrgenommen, dass ich grosse Teile des Plots deswegen nicht verstanden habe. Ja. Das stimmt schon auch. Ja, das Player ist scheiße und die Serie ist halt aber auch von der Tonalität her und so schon auch hart so ganz viel zu gucken. Ja, absolut, total. Aber bist du ein Feedback-Typ? Also wenn du jetzt, ja, weil wenn du jetzt diesen Player nicht gut findest, gibt es dann da irgendwie eine böse Mail von dir an Sky oder gar nichts? Das war der Feedback-Typ. Ja, und zwar habe ich sogar bei Amazon schon mal den geschrieben, ganz am Anfang, als Amazon Prime gelauncht ist, dass ich nicht zufrieden bin, wie man mit Sprachen umgeht. Ja, guter Punkt.
Da habe ich dann den Satz geschrieben bei Netflix, wo ich dachte, so hätte ich den Satz auch nicht anfangen sollen, weil das landet man direkt im Spam-Ordner oder im Höllen-Ordner. Und dann sind alle Preise bei Amazon viel teurer, wenn ich da draufklicke. Ich habe aber gesagt, ja, da kann man einfach während das läuft umschalten und das läuft in der anderen Sprache sofort weiter. und bei Amazon ist es einfach
also manchmal kauft man dann einen Film
oder leht sich den und man kann den nur in einer Sprache dann gucken. Das ist schon ein paar Mal passiert, jetzt habe ich einen Film geliehen und in der falschen Sprache. Dann zahlt man nämlich fünf Euro für einen Drecksfilm, den man eh schon nicht mochte, weil man sich nicht entscheiden konnte, hat man auf den geklickt dann, weil es so, mein Gott, hat man sich darauf einig und dann auch noch in der falschen Sprache, nee, nee.
Nee, absolut furchtbar, völlig unverständlich. Aber auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir immer, das sind ja so viele Stufen, weil das ist ja eine internationale Firma, eine amerikanische Firma, dann bin ich in einem deutschen Ableger, ich bin ja auf Amazon.de. Wie sinnvoll ist es jetzt, an Amazon.de Kundenservice eine deutsche Mail zu schreiben an einen deutschen Community Manager oder was auch immer, an irgendeinen PR-Typen, der dann in seinem deutschen Kopf eine englische Mail schreibt an die Headquarters. Also das wird doch nicht passieren. Ich meine, ich kann ja verstehen, dass Leute auch Feedback wollen, aber das ist so weit weg, zum Beispiel habe ich letztens einen Anruf bekommen von Sky, weil die irgend so, keine Ahnung, irgendwie ein neues Abosystem haben und mich da überreden wollten. Und ich habe, und die meinten so. Ach gut, dass die meisten anderen Schauspieler, ich habe einen Anruf von Sky bekommen, ist immer eine Rolle oder so, und bei dir dir ist ja ein Anruf von Sky bekommen. Ja genau,
weil sie ein billigeres Abo haben.
Wir haben ein bisschen Mitleid mit ihnen. Und
meine die so, ja hallo, guten Tag, sie benutzen Sky
und ich so, ja. Und sind sie zufrieden?
Und ich
ja, ich bin zufrieden.
Weil ich dachte mir, das ist eine
Salesperson, die dieses Abo-Modell
verkaufen soll. Wie sinnvoll ist es,
die jetzt voll zu labern mit,
Man kann es nicht mehr so gut sein, die ist ja Verkäuferin.
Deswegen dachte ich mir auch, bevor ich jetzt da die grosse Tirade ausfahre, lass es einfach. Man spricht meistens mit den falschen Leuten auch. Ja, immer mit den falschen Leuten. Ja, ist ja meine grosse These, die meisten Gespräche kann man einfach lassen. Wie oft sagt ihr die Dinge, die ihr immer loswerden wollt, zu den Leuten, denen sie eigentlich, denen sie adressiert sind? macht man ja nicht. So gut wie nie. Ich rede, ich kotz mich so oft über Leute, bei anderen Leuten aus oder sowas, aber selten erwischt man den richtigen Menschen. Ich glaube, für manche Probleme gibt es auch gar keine Personen, an die man das richten soll. Er kann, also es gibt diesen Mensch nicht, der das machen könnte, weil das ist halt irgendwie, vor allem ich dachte immer, und damit wollte ich Sky schon mal konfrontieren, dass die ihren Player absichtlich schlecht machen, weil die wollen, dass man über so eine Skybox das am Fernsehen schaut. Und deswegen dachte ich, ist deren Browser-App absichtlich schlecht, schlecht programmiert worden. Wollen wir dieses Geräusch thematisieren? Nein. Ist das ein gutes Zeichen oder ein schlechtes Zeichen? Wenn eine Meisenmutter vor der Tür steht und rein will. Achtung, Amsel, es ist keine Reine. Es sind die Sommergeräusche, die ich so vermüchte. Ah, herrlich. Diese herrlichen Sommergeräusche, dieses Nuscheln im Wind, dieses Fiepen in den Baumkronen. Dieses Nuscheln, diese Verspreche. Was? Sorry, nochmal, ein bisschen lauter. Seefahren. Du willst ein Seefahren? Werbung Bus im Wartezimmer des Arztes sitzt? Je nachdem. Hört doch mal ein gescheites Hörbuch. Ich höre mir jetzt tatsächlich gerade die Agatha Christie Bücher an, weil ich das fantastisch finde, völlig vergessen habe, auch die Telekom-Bücher. Ich bin gerade auf so einem Mystery-Trip. Jetzt hilf mir doch mal kurz weiter. Ich kenne mich mit dem Thema gar nicht aus. Wo kann ich denn in Deutschland Hörbücher hören? Na, zum Beispiel bei Thalia. Kennst du ja vielleicht, das gibt es häufiger in meiner Fussgängerzone, ihr könnt einfach auf thalia.de ein Hörbuch-Download-Abo abschliessen. Das kostet 9,95 Euro normalerweise, die ersten 30 Tage ist aber gratis und da gibt es eine riesige Auswahl, 50.000 Titel, aus denen man wählen kann, mindestens ein Hörbuch gibt es pro Monat natürlich, das ganze gibt es online, offline, für Smartphone, für Tablet und überall.
Falls ihr direkt anfangen wollt, geht einfach auf talia.de slash podcast minus ufo und fangt euer Hörbuchabo an.
Viel Spaß beim Hören.
Werbung.
Warst du so schön am See dieses Jahr?
Herrlich, war im Urlaub, schön am See, hab schön Pokémon gespielt mit meinen Jungs, weil ich zack, musste einmal kurz nach Köln fahren mittendrin, aber ansonsten hatte ich eine schöne Zeit im Urlaub, war auf jeden Fall herrlich. Hast du schön Pokémon durchgespielt? Ich hab schön Pokémon durchgezockt, war am See, schön Shirt aus und Bauch in die Sonne. Schön am See, lecker, cooler, schön dreissig, schön dreiss man? Immer die 50. Schön 30, schön 30. Immer 30? 30. Du wechselst nicht wie Hauttyp der 30. Nee, wirklich auch nicht. Aber irgendwann muss man eingestehen, dass man nicht am Ende des Spektrums ist. Es gibt Schlimmere. Und auf der anderen Seite, aber ich frage mich eh, warum man nicht immer das Härteste nehmen sollte bei Sonnencreme. Ich verstehe diese Abstufung auch gar nicht. Wo kommen die denn her? Warum nicht einfach eine
Creme, die schützt? Warum hat man,
ich glaube, die waren zu eitel, um sich einzugestehen,
wir haben keine gute Arbeit
gemacht, war zu schwach.
Und dann haben die gesagt, nö, wir haben einfach
zwei verschiedene Stufen.
Oder es ist ein Marketing-System, dass je höher
die Zahl ist, desto teurer sind die.
Und damit du den Kunden sagst, naja, okay, gut,
da sind ja auch mehr drin.
CO2-Blocker, UV-Killer, UV-Absorber drin.
Von daher kann man auch mal einen Fünfer mehr in die Hand nehmen.
Einen Fünfer mehr. Ist ja kein Problem. Wie viele UV-Blocker sind ein Cent? Ja gut, bei den aktuellen Kursen kannst du da schon, glaube ich. Ich glaube, die waren zu eitel. Weil es gibt ja auch keine Zahnpasta, die nur halb sauber macht. Wo jemand draufschreibt, also Reinigungsfaktor 20. Und dann gibt es eine Zahnppasta Reinigungsfaktor 50. Niemand will auch den 20 nehmen. Das macht gar keinen Sinn. Ich habe keine 30, ich habe 50 mal 50. Oder macht man das, weil man braun werden will? Es ist so halbtransparent. Das hat was, ich glaube, das sind kulturelle Unterschiede. Weil ich habe ja schon mal gesagt, man erkennt die Kultur eines Landes an ihren Automaten. Und es gab mal eine Japanphase, mein Vater hatte zum Beispiel mal eine Japanphase, wo alle japanisch gelernt haben irgendwie und dann hat er erzählt, ja in Japan ist es so, da gibt es Getränkeautomaten und da gibt es dasselbe Getränk in drei Grössen. Und alle kosten gleich viel. Aber der Japaner an sich ist so bescheiden und so vernünftig, dass wenn er nicht mehr trinken will, er auch einfach dann eine kleinere Portion kauft, um damit sich zufrieden zu geben. Für uns Europäer, gierige Kapitalismus Europäer, völlig unvorstellbar. Wir würden uns würden uns selbst bei einem kleinen Durstchen, Durstlein, würden wir uns in den Fünfer rauslassen für den gleichen Preis, um dann den Rest wegzuwerfen oder uns zu übertrinken. Ja. So, und das ist so ist es vielleicht mit dem Sonnenschutzfaktor auch, dass man einfach sagt, hey, ich brauche keine 50 UV-Absorber. Ich bin schon braun geworden. Ich komme auch mit 20. Das finde ich spannend, aber auch interessant, wie es gar nicht funktionieren würde. Ich habe vor allem, Sonnencreme ist schrecklich, und dann hatte ich immer Sonnencreme und dann weine ich immer so viel und dann greife ich mir die Augen und dann muss ich noch mehr weinen. Und dann war ich auf der Heimfahrt vom See, wir fahren ja immer mit dem Fahrrad nach Hause und dann ist mir in mein weinendes, komplett UV-geschütztes auge auch noch eine fliege geflogen ja dass die da drin war und dann habe ich die rausgewischt und dann war ich dann irgendwie war ich nur zu hause und dann bin ich in den zug gestiegen zurück nach köln und dann fahr ich bestimmt schon eine stunde im zug irgendwie gehe mal aufs klo auf die toilette schau in den spiegel und sehe dass ich im spiegel immer noch die flie im Auge habe. Das heißt, ich hatte locker vier, fünf Stunden eine fucking Fliege im Auge, wo a, mich niemand darauf angesprochen hat, b, woran ist diese Fliege gestorben genau? In Filmen ertrunken, im Auge ertrunken. In meinen Tränen. Ja, nee, aber das ist ja die ultimative Filmmetapher für jemand, die stirbt oder du das zu beglaubigen. Wenn du Menschen zeigst im Film, immer der Moment, wo eine Fliege auf ihm landet oder ins Auge geht, ist immer der Moment, wo man sagt, ah, okay, tot.
Ja, das stimmt. Also das war mein Moment. Und mir wäre wirklich fast in Ohmacht gefallen, weil ich hasse das ja, wenn Sachen im Auge sind und so, ich kann das gar nicht haben. Und die Vorstellung, dass ich jetzt drei Stunden lang so eine Fliege auf dem Auge abführe hatte, furchtbar. Also das zum Thema Sonnencreme. Und seitdem hast du eine andere Stimme. Du sprichst wies und Spanisch. Leider kein Italienisch, aber Spanisch habe ich mitgenommen. Seit diese Fliege mir ins Auge gestochen hat, sehe ich alles achtfach. Was heißt Fliege auf Spanisch? Pocque bello. Pocque bello. Klang ausirdänisch. Aber du kannst ja, kann man eigentlich Spanisch italienisch aussprechen? Si. Ja, que pasa? Ne, es geht nicht, ne? Que pasa, que tal? Ne. Aber ich glaube, das ging am ehesten. Que tal muchacho? Que tal? Unos, dos, tres, cuatro. Ja, das ist wie ein Italiener, der Spanisch spricht jetzt. Kann man das tauschen eigentlich? Uno, dos, tres, cuatro. Sin ensilada. Kann man es mal andersrum machen? Also Italienisch Spanisch sprechen? Jetzt weiss ich nicht, wir hören immer keine italienischen Sätze, aber ich nicht spreche. Ja, das ist unglaublich das Grundproblem, dass sich so 220 Folgen Podcast-Ufo zieht, dass wir einfach kein Italienisch sprechen. Übrigens, ich bin ja weiter fleißig dabei, Französisch zu lernen und ich glaube mittlerweile, dass, ich glaube, das ist. Das ist ein Gehirn nicht für Sprachen gemacht. Nein, ich glaube, es ist keine Verschwörungsziele und ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass ich paranoid bin.
Aber ich habe ja in diesem Podcast hier, der bewiesenermaßen auch von Franzosen gehört, wird ja erwähnt, dass ich einige sehr, sehr lukrative Ideen habe, wie man Vokabellern-Apps verbessern könnte. Und da sitzen auch Leute dran. Es haben sich Leute aus der Podcast-Uwe-Community gemeldet, die gesagt haben, ich programmiere das. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Börse gegangen und ich keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist, aber ich glaube, die gehen mit meinen Ideen verantwortungsbewusst um. Schwanger. Kann sein. Und jetzt habe ich nämlich in meiner Vokabellern-App eine Nachricht bekommen, hier, haben Sie Ideen, wie man diese App verbessern könnte? Schreiben Sie hier Ideen rein.
Zutil. Liebe Grüße, Jana. Auf gar keinen Fall gebe ich euch meine eine Million Dollar Ideen.
Das sind Mittelfinger-Emojis zurückgeschickt. Ja, genau.
Und dann das Französisch, fick dich in Französisch geschrieben.
Ja, und dann so Geldberge, einfach so, Geldberg-Emojis. Von daher, ich glaube, die sind mir auf der Schliche. Ich glaube, die wollen mich hacken, die wollen an mich ran, die wollen an meine wahnsinnig wertvollen. Die hören doch zu! Natürlich hören die zu! Na klar! Die hören alles, was wir sagen! Ja! Hier, der Staat hört doch die Podcasts ab! Ja! Der hört doch hier die Fesseln flauschig, hört er sich doch an.
Uns hören doch hier alle zu, wie wir beim Podcast über WC-Ernte reden und schicken uns alle Bilder von WC-Ernten.
In den Handys, da sind noch Chips drin und durch diese Chips hören die die Podcasts, NSA, CIA.
Und die werden geschickt an den Himmel, die Chemtrails hören doch auch mit.
Das ist doch alles in der Cloud, da haben die doch Zugriff auf die ganzen Podcasts. Seid doch nicht so naiv und denken, der NSA könnte keine Podcasts hören. Wer hört die ab, von eurem Handy ab. Ja, wir wurden schon mehrmals abgehört. Ja. Dinge, die ich im Podcast gesagt habe, habe ich schon häufig danach im Internet gefunden. Wirklich? Teilweise auch schon davor. Schon bevor wir sie sagen, stehen sie im Internet. Habe ich sie auf einen G-Gag gefunden. Schon bevor ich einen Witz gemacht habe hier, waren die teilweise schon auf einen Nein-Gag. Also wer da nicht anfängt langsam aufzuwachen, der ist wirklich spät dran. Ich bin woken. Ja, wischt euch mal die Naivität aus den Augen. Ja, und die Flieger auch gleich mit. Guten Morgen. Pockebel. Buenos Dias, Buenos Mo... Oh, ich habe Coco geguckt, den Film. Den Disney, ich bin jetzt großer Disney-Fürst. Den mit Coco Chanel oder den Animationsfilm? Den Animationsfilm. Weil ich habe jetzt Disney-Plats für mich entdeckt. Lass mich nicht rein. Doch, klar, genau das. Aber es ist schon cool, wenn man da die ganzen Disney-Pixar-Klassiker angucken kann.
Und, oh, hab ich geweint.
Ja, bei Coco?
Ich hab bei allen, ich hab ein paar Filme geguckt.
Ich hab auch wieder das Grosse Krabbeln geguckt, wieder geweint. Nenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenenen.
Wie heisst der Fips?
Flip?
Flip.
Der nervt zu hart.
Ja.
Aber die anderen Charaktere sind toll. Nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, aber wie heißt der, Fips?
Flip? Nee.
Flip, der nervt zu hart.
Ja.
Aber die anderen Charaktere sind toll und bunt und ich lach mich abund.
Aber Coco war ganz toll, super schwer zu nachts erzählende Prämisse, weil er braucht die Gitarre, weil er gerne spielen will, dann muss er bei einem Contest mitmachen, dann kriegt er die Gitarre, aber dann klaut er die, aber dann ist in der Totenwelt, braucht er dann aber auch eine Gitarre, dann muss er auch bei diesem Festival gewinnen und so weiter. Ganz schwierige Prämisse, aber ein ganz toller Film. Aber für Kinder, die vor allem Totenrituale und Gitarren lieben, eigentlich der perfekte Nachmittag. Hatte auch nicht viel zu sehen, der Film war auch nicht so wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Komisch bei den ganzen tanzenden Skeletten. Kinder immer nur Argo schauen wollen.
Kinder lieben Argo schauen wollen. Immer Argo, Argo, Argo, Argo. Hat übrigens auch niemand unseren Aufruf verfolgt, dass alle mal ihre Argo-DVD, auch weil die Deutschen in Japan hätten das gemacht. Nee, unser Hashtag Argos missen. Argo raus, Argo muss raus. Niemand gefolgt, null Hashtag, null Tweets mit dem Hashtag. Okay, also, wir wollen jetzt, dass der Hashtag Argo muss raus trendet. Ich will, dass ihr alle eure Kopie von Argo rausstellt. Ja. Und man guckt, dass mal alle Argos die Besitzer wechseln, weil der Film offensichtlich nicht die Aufmerksamkeit bekommt, die er verdient. Weil weil wie gesagt, ich habe mehrmals jetzt Argos auf der Straße gesehen.
Und falls ihr eine Arztpraxis habt, stellt doch einfach mal neben eure sticken Wissenschaftsbücher einfach mal ein paar Kopien Argo. Oder lasst halt im Wartezimmerfernseher, lasst da mal Argo laufen. Es ist ein toller Film. Jetzt kommt ja bald, also wir glaube ich waren ja beide grosse Fans von Inside Out, der Prämisse, dass Gefühle sprechen können und der ganze Film im Kopf von einem kleinen Mädchen stattfindet. Das ist mal eine Prämisse. Und jetzt gibt es ja bald der Soul, glaube ich, mit den Seelen, die sprechen können. Da gibt es ja diesen Jazzmusiker und dann diese Welt der Seelen. glaube ich, bevor man geboren wird, hängen die Seelen da irgendwo rum. Flotin redet mit seiner Waagehand, er macht die Waagegest. Aber auch ein, eins meiner Lieblingswörter im Englischen ist handwavy. Ja, it's such a handwavy approach, einfach so, ja, ja, das machen wir schon später so. Handwinkender. Und übersetzbar. Handwink? Ein handwinkender Ansatz. Ich meine, das könnte man schon machen, so ein Handwinkender, aber das würde man glaube ich nicht verstehen, aber wir können es durchsetzen. Ein Handwinkender Ansatz. Ja. Halt einfach so, ja, das ist ein Handwinkender. Handwedeln. Handwedeln. Handwedeln. Ja, ja, ja, ja, das machen wir schon später. Und dann hast du halt so Seelen, die halt dann irgendwie dann in der Hölle oder keine Ahnung. Ja, so ein Handwedeln das Versprechen zum Beispiel auch. Ja, genau. Er hat mir mit so einem handwedelnden Versprechen gesagt, dass er mir noch was mitbringt vom Kiosk. Ja, genau. Und wie machen wir das dann? Ja, das macht er so. Ja, es war eine handwedelnde Erklärung. Handwedelnde Antwort. Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt auf diesen Soul-Film, wie die das machen mit Seelen, wo die sind, worüber die sprechen. Wie die wohl aussehen. Ich finde es ja immer spannend, weil manchmal höre ich Prämissen und ich überlege mir immer, weil klar, nachdem man den Film gesehen hat, ist es leicht zu sagen, das ist eine brillante Prämisse, weil der Film gut war. Aber ich überlege mir immer, hätte ich die Prämisse auch gut gefunden, wenn sie ein nicht genialer Mensch mir gesagt hätte, bevor der Film gemacht wurde. Weil man muss ja so ehrlich sein, dass manchmal man einfach ... Ich erinnere mich an die Zeit, wo ich dir im guter Arbeitraum gesagt habe, die Prämisse von How to Sell Drugs erzählt habe und deine Antwort war, ja, aber wer will denn eine Serie sehen, wo die ganze Zeit jemand vom PC sitzt? Das war wirklich deine Antwort. Also die Antwort, du hast niemand, du hast wirklich ein nicht genialer Mensch, hat dir von einer Prämisse erzählt und deine Antwort war, nee, das ist für unsinn. Genau, und deswegen denke ich immer mal, und ja, da lag ich offensichtlich falsch und er war jetzt eine fantastische Serie geworden. Und deswegen denke ich mir auch immer so, hätte ich die Idee auch gut gefunden, wenn jemand gesagt hätte, ja, Gefühle, und dann denke ich mir, wo wir sprechen denn Gefühle die ganze Zeit? Wie sollen die denn aussehen? Die ganze Zeit Gefühle sehen, die im Kopf ein Mädchen rumsitzen, da passiert ja nichts. Und wahrscheinlich hast du schon, weil ich habe mich ja nicht beeindrucken lassen von dir, aber ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Menschen du schon erniedrigt hast und einfach gestoppt hast mit ihrem kreativen Überschwall. Und du hast die einfach gestoppt. Ich sehe tatsächlich, ich sehe oft zu sehr die negativen Sachen und ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass ich einfach faul bin. Nein. Und dass ich mir einfach denke, je weniger Ideen entstehen, desto weniger müssen wir machen. Du hast ja nicht mal arbeiten müssen davon. Ja, aber du hast Angst gehabt, dass du mal eine Rollerin bekommst und dann für deinen Urlaub einen Drehtag nach Köl. Genau. Du denkst halt ein bisschen weiter. Genau, ja. Ja, aber das ist spannend. Finde ich nämlich auch interessant. Ich habe damals diese Idee gehört von Yesterday, dem Film. Ja. Von dem Film, wo die Beatles plötzlich nicht mehr existieren, aber einer sich noch an alle Songs erinnern kann und dann damit berühmt wird. Und in meinem Kopf fiel mir auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel dazu ein.
Und dem Film war dann auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich den Film geguckt und der war auch nicht so gut.
Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, vielleicht war eine scheiß Prämisse einfach.
Ist aber eigentlich spannend.
Man sollte, bevor man einen Film sieht, die Prämisse
sich durchlesen und dann einfach mal auf den Zettel schreiben,
was fällt mir dazu ein,
coole Szenen, die mir gefallen hat.
So eine Bucketlist.
Und dann den Film gucken und schauen, ob man vielleicht was getroffen hat
oder ob man ganz anders liegt. Das haben ja die
Macher von Spider-Man Homecoming
gemacht, einen Film, den wir ja auch beide toll fanden.
Die haben sich dann eine
Bucketlist geschrieben, so mit Dingen, wo sie
Spider-Man immer schon mal sehen wollten.
Spider-Man auf dem Golfplatz,
wo keine Hochhäuser rum sind,
der muss rennen. Das ist lustig.
Also einfach mal so ein Bullshit-Bingo zu machen am Anfang und so. Dinge, die ich immer schon mal sehen wollte von dieser Figur. Das finde ich toll. Und dann einen Film schreiben und immer wenn du dann etwas brauchst, irgendwie einen Ort, wo ein Kampf stattfindet oder einen Ort, wo eine Szene stattfindet, kannst du dann noch zurückgreifen auf deine Bucketlist. Ja. Golfplatz. Spire mehr auf dem Golfplatz, rennt. Perfekt. Man muss einfach rennen, ist wie ein Mensch. Das ist wirklich lustig. Ja, das ist fantastisch. Das ist ja nicht auch irgendwann in der U-Bahn oder so, man muss irgendwo hinfahren. Oder ich glaube, irgendein Superheld ist das irgendwann mal, der eine Superheld, der nicht fliegen kann, der dann mit der U-Bahn fahren muss. Ich glaube, war das nicht sogar ein Sketch von irgendwas? Von den Avengers können ja zwei fliegen. Iron Man kann fliegen, kann Thor fliegen? Weiß ich nicht. Also es können auf jeden Fall nicht alle fliegen. Das heißt, einer kann immer fliegen, und es ist immer so eine Trennung, die die fliegen können und die die mit dem Uber fahren müssen oder so. Die dann da hin und dann einfach später kommen oder so. Auch nervig. Das fand ich immer toll, wo bei Pokémon, wo dann Glurak so ein Schick genommen hat und geflogen ist. Ja, oder mal anfangen, wo alle auf dem Lapras stehen und auf dem Fahren im Intro. Ja, auch gut. Aber das Intro ist generell toll. Ey, Lapras ist tatsächlich eines der krassesten Pokémon, was man nicht denkt aus der Serie. Unfassbar gut, Eis ist eh so krass overpowered. Ich bin noch ein bisschen Pokémon-Nachie. Eis ist overpowered? Eis ist mega overpowered. Aber nicht im echten Leben. Nee, gar nicht. Es ist im echten Leben wahnsinnig underpowered, ehrlich gesagt. Wahnsinnig. Ich meine, du ziehst den Anorager an. Ja. Das war's. Nee, aber im Sommer ist Eis nichts wert. Also ohne Scheiß, es ist so schnell weg. Naja, aber wie viel gibst du für ein Eis aus an deinem heißen Sandstrand? So, und jetzt kannst du mal gucken, wie wichtig Eis ist. Ein Fuffi? Ja. Angebot, Nachfrage. Angebot, bestimmt Nachfrage. Habe ich neulich in irgendeinem Konzept gelesen. Aber Nachfrage, bestimmt auch Angebot. Nee. Hast du mir das Gefühl, du entwickelst dich zurück? Weil du warst mal eifriger Wohlstand für alle Hörer und mittlerweile bist du wieder am Grundwissen angekommen. Es ist auch wieder, wie heißt das, das Syndrom, weiß ich jetzt wieder nicht, aber bestätigt das, was ich sagen will. Je mehr man über etwas weiss, desto weniger weiss man darüber. Ja. Das hat auch einen Namen, das habe ich auch immer gewusst. Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr viel. Ja, aber da sind wir wieder. Ich vergesse eine Menge, wirklich, das merke ich. Ich gucke mir jetzt auch wieder die gleichen Videos an, die ich mir schon mal angeschaut habe. Bei YouTube findet man tolle Sachen, zum Beispiel so Mathe-Vorlesungen oder sowas. Die kann man sich angucken. Gibt es diese tolle Frau Birkenbiel, die ganz toll alle Dinge erklärt. Habe ich mal alles verstanden gefühlt? Jetzt habe ich wieder alles vergessen, jetzt gucke ich mich wieder an. Dann Chaos-Theorie. Habe ich verstanden, durch so eine YouTube-Essay-Videoreihe. Habe ich alles mal gewusst? Man muss ja echt mal ein ernstes Wörtchen mit seinem Gehirn reden, wo man denkt, warum merkst du die das denn nicht? Ja, weil du es nicht brauchst, weil du es nicht anwendest, natürlich nicht. Ja, aber gut, ich brauche die 151 Pokémon-Namen auch seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr. Natürlich, aber die brauchst du jedes Jahr, brauchst du sie. Ja, aber Hettan doch nicht, Arbok. Aber die kann man Cobra und Natter, kann man toll merken. Deswegen ist es einfacher zu merken, ja, stimmt schon. Aber ja, es ist nervig, aber ich habe tatsächlich auch versucht, ein bisschen meinen Horizont zu erweitern auf YouTube. Und zwar dachte ich mir ... Zwei Schlangen-Pokémon, aber kein Pinguin-Pokémon. Weil Schlangen sind so, okay, gut, aber auch in Raupen-Pokémon, es gibt diese länglichen Pokémon, sind genau wie ich mir dachte. Ja, diese Dratini und so, die sind auch weird. Warte, die ist ja auch noch, stimmt. Und wie ich mir aber auch dachte, es ist unfassbar, wie überrepräsentiert behörnte Tiere im Sternzeichen-Kosmos sind. Es gibt Widder, Steinbock, Stier und ich meine, es gibt noch einen. Aber es gibt nicht so viele. Wahrscheinlich hat der Typ irgendwie, Paulokrates, der sich diese Bilder ausgedacht hat, der war halt riesen Paarhufer-Fan. Hörner-Fan. Und fand es halt mega geil, die da reinzubauen. Jemand anders hätte da ein Pinguin reingemacht oder sowas, stimmt schon. Es gibt nicht so viele Tiere als Sternzeichen und die meisten davon haben Hörner. Wassermann, das ist so strange. Bleib halt dann bei deinem Tierschema. Weißt du, du hast mit Tieren angefangen und dann Waage. Und dann fallen dir keine Tiere mehr ein und dann Waage Jungfrau, was soll das denn sein, Wassermann, lächerlich. Wassermann Jungfrau ist wieder für mich eine Schublade. Aber ist das eigentlich noch weiter? Du hast ja enge Connections zu Hollywood und Hollywood ist ja immer auf der Suche nach dem neuen heißen Franchise. So Superhelden gehen schon langsam irgendwie der Dampf aus. Wann kommen die Sternzeichen?
Eigentlich so, die neuen Avengers, die Sternzeichen. Jeder auf der Welt kann damit was anfangen. Chinesischer Magma mag ich gar nicht. Vielleicht gibt es in anderen Kulturen andere Bilder. Lustigerweise ist es einfach Avengers. Wassermann ist Aquaman, Schütze, Hawkeye. Es ist im Prinzip einfach Ja, okay, gut, aber dann hast du halt noch einen Krebs, das ist Iron Man, hat auch die Schale. Eine boring Version von Avengers, ist Sternzeichen. Ja, ist Sternzeichen, einfach Wassermann ist eigentlich ganz geil. Ja, Aquaman. Ja, und dann hast du noch, ja, Waage ist halt ein bisschen lame. Über lame. Hollywood gehen offensichtlich die Ideen aus. Du ist Zwilling, Waage und den Bärenmarke Bär.
Und man versucht, so ein verzweifelter Autor versucht, das irgendwie zusammenzuflicken.
Wo würdest du, jetzt mach mal eine Liste, wo würdest du Waage gerne sehen?
So Szenen, auf die du Bock hättest, mal deine Waage Bucketlist.
Auf welche geilen Szenen hättest du Bock mit Waage?
Mit Waage, also erstmal die Frage, ist Waage denn so ein, wie man das kennt von Die schönes Biest, so animierter Kram? Ach so, nee, nee, normale Waage halt. Ach so. Ja, auf dem Schiff. Aber worauf hättest du Bock? Auf dem Schiff, wenn ich bin, weil da ist die nervös, glaube ich, die Waage. Ja, okay, Moment mal, Federn sind plötzlich schwerer als Eisen? Nein, das ist wegen der Flut. Dann im Gericht etwas in die Waagschale werfen, da bin ich auch so wortkosmosmäßig. Aber irgendwie so auf einem Hochhaus oder so? Da ist die einfach eine Waage auf dem Hochhaus. Es geht darum, worauf du mal gerne Bock hast, Stefan. Lass mal deinen Fantasiefreien Lauf. Waage im Weltraum, Waage im Weltraum. Waage im Weltraum finde ich toll. Geil, schreib's auf, schreib's auf. Kein Gewicht im Weltraum. Perfekt, perfekt, perfekt, denn wenn man da was auf die Waage legt, ist es egal. Waage im Wilden Westen, Waage auf einer Wippe, Waage auf einer Wippe, schreib's auf, Waage im Wilden Westen, Warum nicht? Geil, perfekt, guck mal, wir haben ja schon einen Film, wir können es immer direkt pitchen. Wassermann in Lava. Mega gut, Wassermann im Schwimmbad, an der Rutsche.
Wassermann bei den Olympischen Spielen. Schwimmt gegen Michael Phirps und Michael Phirps gewinnt. Wassermann wird in die Lebenskrise gestossen, fängt an zu trinken.
Ja, weiter. Was trinkt Wassermann? Kakao, Weinschorle. Dann lernt er Aquaman kennen, weil er sich auch betrinkt, ist dann noch verwirrter, weil es gibt neben Wassermann auch noch Aquaman. Die beiden werden wieder in Lebensgriffe geworfen, weil sie nicht wissen, weil sie dachten, sie wären einzigartig, sind sie nicht. Erst Feinde, später Freunde. Wassermann im Weltraum? Wassermann auf dem Mars? Findet Wasser auf dem Mars? Perfekt. Findet Eis auf dem Mars. Eismann? Feuermann vom Eismann. Sobald du das Wassermann-Franchise anfängst, muss irgendwie auch Feuermann kommen. Nee, Wassermann vom Eiswagen. Also beim Eismann. Oder hat halt einen mega langweiligen Bürojob. Das ist dann eher so ein Margin-Call-Szenario, wo irgendwie Finanzkrise oder so, mit Wassermann in der Hauptrolle. Ich würde gerne mal so einen Superman-Film, also meinen Superman-Film, wenn man jetzt sagt, Stefan, die übernimmt das Superman-Franchise, wer einfach nur Clark Kent, aber es war so ein The Post-artiger Film. Ja, genau. Weil der ist ja Journalist, Clark Kent und alle warten jetzt auf den Moment, wo er dann die Brille abnimmt und den Superman-Overall aussieht.
Nein, es bleibt The Post. Er deckt so ein Kinderpornografiering oder sowas auf.
In Boston auch. Auch eine spannende Geschichte, aber es kommt... Total ernst. Aber ja, es ist auch Superman, er ist so ein Betitelungsbild. Auf dem Poster.
Schreibst du was auf so einem Blog?
Ja, genau.
Telefonate.
Eigentlich nur The Post mit Mark Ruffalo.
Das ist ja irgendwie so ein Fall.
Oh, geil.
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Wem mal Ruffalo. Das ist ja irgendwie so ein Fall. Oh, geil. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Wäre ich mal Ruffalo jetzt oder was? Guck mal, das wäre ein guter Sketch. Ich hätte gerne wieder einen Sketch-Channel. Wäre echt gut. Manchmal fallen mir auch so Sachen ein, wo ich mir denke, das müsste man jetzt einfach machen. Geht nicht. Ich habe jetzt versucht, mich ein bisschen meinen Horizont zu erweitern auf YouTube. Vor allem, weil ich mir immer denke, ist nicht unser Horizont total eng?
Wir kennen immer nur unsere Umwelt, wir haben irgendwie Tinder-Radius zehn Kilometer.
Was kann man da überhaupt Interessantes finden?
Ist die Welt nicht viel grösser?
Auch zum Beispiel Thema Musik.
Man hört immer nur dieselbe Musik.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal so einen schönen asiatischen Knaller gehört, so ein geiles Album aus Asien? Hörst du da nicht? Nee. Hörst du nicht? Hör ich nicht. Afrikanische Musik, null Plays im Jahre 2020 von dir. Zero. Null. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, erweitere ich meinen Horizont und ich bin total eingestiegen in mongolischer Kehlkopfgesang. Ja, ja, bin ich total drin. Da gibt es einige richtig coole Videos. Da bin ich so weit drin, ich habe schon Urlaubideen, um das zu lernen. Du kannst nämlich da hin und auch so Nepal und so und kannst dann da Kehlkopfgesang lernen. Das ist so cool. Mit den Yaks auf dem, das machen wir mal.
Das ist so cool, vor allem die haben ja auch diesen Oberton-Gesang, was total abgespaced klingt, wo du so zwei Töne gleichzeitig singst und was, das ist das Zeichen für Oktafe. Du hast das Surferzeichen genommen, aber du meinst zwei Töne übernommen. Ja, weil man, also damit rechnet man nicht. Du denkst dir ja, die sitzen in so einer Steppe und irgendwie so volkstümliche Musik und dann haben die plötzlich diesen Alien-Gesang, der da so ganz merkwürdig drin ist, aber irgendwie auch passt. Und singt damit dann Sarah Connor. Ja genau, eigentlich, das dachte mir nämlich auch. From Zero to Hero. Ich habe nämlich auch eine Musikerin auf YouTube gefunden, die so diese traditionellen chinesischen Gitarren spielt, die aber auch so auf dem Boden liegen, damit aber moderne Songs covert. Und das hat auch irgendwie was ganz eigenes, auch eigentlich ganz cool. Und dann mein absolutes Highlight, das ich gefunden habe, kleiner Shoutout an der Stelle an Armin Küpper. Ich weiß nicht, ob du Armin Küpper kennst, aber der hat für sich eine ganz eigene Nische auf YouTube gefunden. Und zwar ist das ein Jazz-Saxophonist, der in Amerika wohnt. Und anscheinend in der Gegend, wo er wohnt, wird gerade irgendwas gebaut und da liegt ein riesiges Rohr. ein riesiges Rohr rum, also wirklich hunderte Meter langes Rohr, riesig. Und er hat einen Channel gemacht, ich guck mal was, worüber wir im Rohr alles geht. Und er stellt sich mit seinem Saxophon vor dieses Rohr und das hat halt das härteste Echo der Welt, dieses Rohr, weil das ist halt wirklich ein kilometerlanges Rohr.
Und der spielt dann sozusagen ein Duett mit sich selbst, mit seinem eigenen Echo, weil das immer so zwei Sekunden später kommt. Wow. Und er halt dann so mit sich selbst spielt. Und das ist das Shit. Und das finde ich so geil, weil es gibt halt nur eine Person, die das spielt, weil niemand hat so ein riesiges Rohr einfach bei sich rumliegen. Das ist fantastisch. Und der hat wirklich Millionen Klicks. Also absoluter Shoutout. Komm gerne mal in einem Podcast vorbei, wenn du Bock hast. Wir hätten Bock, mit dir über dieses Rohr zu sprechen. Mega. Aber es ist natürlich schwierig für Kinder, die sagen, ich will das auch lernen, dieses Rohr. Aber gibt es halt nicht. Aber schön, dass wir beide bei Musik gelandet sind. Ich bin jetzt bei einer Pianistin gelandet, die vloggt. Und die immer so, weil es ist spannend, Pianisten sieht man auf der Bühne ab und zu, aber wie die üben und so kann man sich nicht richtig vorstellen.
Ist das diese nahe Sohl?
Ja, genau.
Vor allem habe ich sie gefunden durch das Video, ich darf mir ein Steinway-Piano aussuchen, was das Fantastischste, ich war noch nie so befriedigt von einem Video, weil sie und man erlebt das ja quasi mit ihr zusammen und sie hat einfach, sie wird jetzt von Steinway gesponsert, weil sie halt diesen Vlog auch macht und sie darf umsonst ein Steinway Piano bekommt sie und darf sich in ihre Wohnung stellen und liefern lassen und das hat sie dann halt, das mietet man dann immer so, aber sie kriegt es kostenlos. Und das Video bestand einfach nur daraus, sie fährt zur Steinway-Fabrik und kann sich von einem Riesenraum, wo ganz viele Steinway-Pianos stehen, eins aussuchen. Und dann hat sie diese Kamera an den Fixpunkt gestellt und geht dann von Piano zu Piano. Und es ist das gleiche Piano. Es sind ganz viele. Die klingen alle gleich, aber halt alle unfassbar anders. Und dann spielt sie die alle an und so und dann hat sie so zwei ausgenommen, die sie nicht geguckt findet, dann hat sie den speziellen Wunsch auch, weil sie will nicht so einen brillanten Sound, sie will eher einen weichen, vielseitig und dann geht das Video so eine halbe Stunde und dann hat sie sich eins ausgesucht und dann wird es geliefert und es ist so befriedigend zu gucken. Natürlich will man mal ein Piano haben. Absolut. Ich habe eine Zeit lang in München gewohnt. Und in Lime, da muss man immer umsteigen, egal. Aber da war auch so ein Lagerhaus. Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Fabrik war, sondern eher ein Lagerhaus. Und da stand auch groß Steinway & Sons drauf. Und ich habe immer, wenn ich da umsteigen musste und da gewartet habe, da muss man da so zehn Minuten warten, bis die andere S-Bahn kommt, habe ich mir immer gedacht, habe ich mir so ein Heist ausgedacht, wie man da so Flügel klaut, weil ich glaube niemand, eben, und ich glaube, das ist genau der Schlüssel, niemand erwartet, also einerseits ist Steinway halt so wahnsinnig wertvoll, ich weiß nicht, was da so ein Flügel kostet, 100.000 oder so.
Nicht ganz, aber ja.
Wird schon was wert sein. Wobei man sich überlegen muss, ob es einen grossen Abnehmer-Schwarzmarkt gibt für Steinway-Flügel, weil du willst ja schon einen echten Steinway, den kaufst du dann von echt mir. Und die Leute, die Piano wollen, they don't strike me.
Ja.
Als Leute, die ...
Hey, hast du ein Flügel?
Hast du ein Flügel?
Ja, was ist ein echter Steinway?
Ja, lass mal, zeig mal, lass mal zeigen. Na ja, guck mal, hier, der hat einen brillanteren Klang. Taugt der auch was? Nii, im Ernst!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, komm ein bisschen runter.
Ja, zeig mal, zeig mal, was da drauf war.
Guck mal, der hat einen ziemlich brillanten Klang.
Der hat einen ziemlich brillanten Klang?
aber ich will auch ein bisschen was Der hat einen ziemlich breiten Klang. Nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nenegebaugeliefert, habe ich jetzt gesehen. Ich habe auf jeden Fall nie eine Möglichkeit gefunden, wie man da was klauen kann. weil ich dachte mir immer so, keine Ahnung, man fährt vor, hat einen Gabelstapler hinten drin, so wie Kit, der hinten so aus dem Lastwagen fährt. Mir gefällt die Idee. Total. Mir gefällt die Heist-Idee, zu sagen, was ist das Teuerste, was aber, erst mal egal, wie gross es ist, wie schwer es zu klauen ist, ist mir egal, weil ich glaube, auf jeden Fall, man hat sich irgendwie auf Gold, Geld, auf so Dinge eingeschossen, Diamanten, Juweliere, nein. Was sind teure Dinge, die man auch klauen kann? Cern zum Beispiel. Dieser Neutronenbeschleuniger in Cern. Zu gross. Ja, aber guck mal, ich glaube ... Das könnte ein großes Rohr sein, in das der andere Sachsefin bustet. Ich glaube, niemand rechnet damit, dass das gestohlen wird.
Du könntest da hingehen und sagen, ich will mich hier nur umgucken, okay, und dann klaust du das halt.
Die stellen da so kleine mini-schwarze Löcher her.
Das kannst du klauen.
Antimaterie.
Antimaterie kann man klauen.
Das kannst du klauen.
Das fällt ja niemandem auf, wenn das verschwindet. Stell ich ins Regal dann. Ist schwierig. Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, wirklich Dinge zu klauen. Warte, mal so ganz teuren. Oh, das wird dir gefallen. Netflix-Doku Sour Grapes. Und zwar über einen Weinfälscher. Gesehen? Nee, habe ich schon gehört. Ja, schau es dir an. Und ich weiß, dass dir das gefallen wird, weil ich kenne den neuen Stefan. Du glaubst, ich hänge immer noch dem alten Playmobil-Stefan hinterher? Nein, ich habe voll und ganz den neuen, coolen Lifestyle-Stefan akzeptiert, der sich solche Weindokus reinzieht. Ja, der auch sich gerne mal einen guten Wein gönnt mittlerweile. Ich habe wirklich... Schönen Rosé? Schönen Bianco Piago? Manchmal auch im Sommerlicht gerne einen schönen Rosé. Bianco Adiagio? Sisi. Adiagio. Ja, ja. Schöne Rosé, schön Bianco, Piago. Im Sommer licht gerne schön Rosé. Bianco, Adagio.
Sisi, Adagio. Sisi, Adagio. Und da dachte ich, als ich diese Doku gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, fuck, was für eine geile Serienidee. So ein Weinfälscher, diese ganze Weinwelt, irgendwie dann schön, Kamerafahrten durch die Weinberge. Du willst so Weinberge. Viel Drohnenfahrten, plätschernde roter Wein plätschert in so einem Fass, geschwenkt in so einem Weinglas. Versicherungen sind ja eigentlich super kompliziert, aber mit Clark kann man seine Versicherungen jetzt digital an der App managen. Ich muss mich nicht mehr um meine Versicherung kümmern, sondern habe eine App, die sich da einfach um alles kümmert? So ganz outsourcen würde ich es nicht, also ich würde noch grob im Kopf haben, ich habe Versicherungen, aber du kannst tatsächlich sehr übersichtlich sehen, was du hast. Mega. Und hast alles auf einem Blick, was mich immer nervt, dass ich wahnsinnig Papierkram habe und nicht genau weiß, wo was liegt und so.
Ich hatte teilweise vier Haftpflichtversicherungen, einfach weil ich nicht wusste, welche ich habe. Richtig. Das kann in demnächst nicht passieren oder du bist einfach nur strunzendum. Gut. Und das Beste ist, wenn ihr euch da jetzt anmeldet bei Clark, bei dem es nämlich ganz einfach möglich ist, alles zu sehen. Und wenn ihr einfach zwei bestehende Versicherungen in die App hochladet, dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr bei der Registrierung den Gutscheincode UFO angebt, einen 30 Euro Amazon Gutschein abstauben. Toll! Und bei Fragen helfen dir sofort die ausgebildeten Clark-Versicherungsexperten, die sind nämlich die ganze Zeit per Telefon, Chat oder wie auch immer ohne Wartezeit komplett verfügbar. Die arbeiten ja die ganze Zeit für dich. Kannst du dir vorstellen? Ich überlege gerade wegen Clark Kent. Kennt ihr Clark? Sorry. Und jetzt zurück zum Podcast-Ufo. Clark! Werbung. Ich bin, ich kann so schlecht klauen, ich war neulich, kam ich an einem Blumengeschäft vorbei, wo draußen, das war zu, aber alle Blumen, das ganze Sortiment war draußen und da war eine Kasse. Und dann stand dann hier bitte das Geld reinlegen. Es war so eine Vertrauensbasis. Ja, aber das ist ja kein Clown. Doch, es wäre ja Clown. Ja, aber du kannst dich auf Vertrauensbasis klauen. Nee, was? Nein, die Idee ist ja... Die hindert ja niemand daran, zu klauen. Das ist ja keine Leistung. Aber selbst das kann ich nicht. Das ist ja noch nie mal verboten, glaube ich. Das ist verboten. Nein. Das wäre Klauen. Ich glaube nicht, dass du ... Nee, wenn da steht, zahlen Sie, bitte zahlen Sie. Nein, nein, hier das Geld reinwerfen dann. Das ist eine Vertrauensbasis. Vertrauensobststand gibt es auch häufig. Das ist eine Grauzone. Ich glaube, es ist keine Grauzone, da hast du es nicht klauen. Ja, aber wenn du vor Gericht sagst, sorry, ich dachte, das ist sonst. Diese Pixie-Bücher, die draußen vor der Buchhandlung stehen. Ja, dann nehme ich mir mal ein paar mit. Die darf man nicht klauen. Klar darf man die klauen. Alles ähnlich. Man darf manche Sachen klauen. Das gehört dazu, doch wirklich. Das steht im Gesetz. Die meisten Sachen darf man nicht klauen, aber ein paar schon. Ihr merkt schon, was man klauen darf und was nicht. Ich habe nämlich jetzt für mich entdeckt, du wirst lachen, auf meine neue Wohnung. Ich gebe mir gerade noch Mühe, die soll gut aussehen immer. Das Wohnungsthema, ey, das ist echt, wie lange geht das jetzt noch weiter? Naja, ich bin immer noch neu da. Wie viele Sommerpausen müssen wir noch machen? In drei Jahren bin ich immer noch erst drei Jahre da. Okay. Und ich gebe mir noch Mühe, die ist noch mega aufgeräumt und so. Und dann steht auf dem Tisch mittlerweile auch eine Vase und da sind Blumen drin. Frische Blumen. Die hole ich mir im Laden. Wo hast du die Vase her? Vasenladen. Wasenladen? Wasenladen neben dem Blumenladen. Immer der Vase nach oder wie hieß der? Ja, Vase hoch. Und dann tatsächlich gab es den Punkt, wo ich zum ersten Mal in dem Leben in einen Laden gegangen bin und einen Blumenstrauß wollte. Es war so ein Laden, aber da sind dann ganz viele Blumen aufgestellt in der Mitte
und dann sagt, dann geht man da rein,
es gibt keine fertige Blumensträuße.
Und das war für mich schwierig, der Moment, weil
es war so, in meinem Kopf dachte ich,
ich nehme jetzt einen und gehe nach Hause damit.
Und dann ist das Thema auch erstmal durch.
Ja, wie eine Tanke, einfach so ein schön...
Nee, das Ding ist, du gehst da rein und dann
guckst du dich kurz um und du siehst keinen Blumenstrass, der fertig ist. Dann sah ich aber diese ganzen Behälter in der Mitte, wo die einzelnen Blumen drin standen, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, ganz billig, das heißt, die Idee war dann, dass man sich das so gemischte Tüte mässig zusammenstellt. Also bin ich hingegangen, nee, erst mal bin ich wieder rausgegangen und habe eine Freundin angerufen wie man das macht und die hat dann gesagt ja, ne, du musst einen Preis sagen und dann fiel mir eine, ja, wie gemischte Tüte, du sagst einen Preis ich hätte gerne für zwei Euro jetzt was dann gerne von davon, davon, davon, davon und dann machen die das so, dann musste man beim Blumenstrauß hat sie mir dann aber nicht gesagt, wie viel man dann sagen soll, wie viel Geld kostet so ein Blumenstrauß muss ich jetzt ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie treibend man da ist, also bin ich reingegangen und habe gesagt, ja, ich hätte gerne einen Blumenstrauss und dann meinten die, wie viel Geld denn, dann habe ich gesagt, 30 Euro und dann war das Gesicht hat gesagt, also ich konnte aus dem Gesicht nicht lesen, ob das zu viel oder zu wenig war, was ich gesehen habe, war unangemessen. Und du so, nee, nee, 80 Euro. Sorry, hab ich versprochen. Also das Gesicht hat gesagt unangemessen, aber okay. Also es war jetzt nicht meilenweit davon entfernt, aber es war schon so ein Stirnrunzler zu sehen, kurzer Stirnrunzler zu sehen. Also ich war da mit With the Flow, und da war die Frage,
wie soll denn aussehen?
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, am liebsten ein bisschen höher,
gerne nicht so breit,
vier Fragezeichen im Gesicht,
weil dann ist man so,
man bestellt Wein und weiß nicht genau,
was wollen sie denn für einen, ja, was haben sie halt. Was sind die Kategorien?
Ich wusste nicht, worin ich dann
fiel mir ein, weil dann war so,
was für Farben denn?
Und dann drehst du dich halt um
und es ist alles bunt.
Es sind alles sehr grün,
gelb, blau, rot.
Grün? Stängelgrün.
Und so habe ich gesagt. Ich will einen Blumenstrauß
komplett grün.
Geben Sie mir grüne Blüten, grüne
Blätter, ich will komplett grün.
Einfach. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, nee, so gern Pastellfarben. Oh Gott. Weil das fiel mir ein. Das ist der schlimmste Kunde der Welt. Nee, und das war der Moment, wo ich sie hatte. Echt? Das geht? Ach so, da habe ich es schon eingeschätzt. Nee, Pastellfarben ging. Aber das habe ich mir noch aufgeschnappt. Ich habe es aufgeschnappt, von dem Mann vor mir, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ah, ja, ja, okay. Dann habe ich es aufgeschnappt und dann habe ich's gesagt und dann fand sie es okay und dann hat sie mir das zusammengestellt und es sagt gut aus am Ende. Ich kann mir vielleicht ein Bild holen. Es war am Ende ein Blumenstrauß, beim ersten Mal hat es funktioniert, dann nach ein paar Wochen war der im Arsch, dann hab ich den doch mal das versucht und bin dann mit so einem Selbstbewusstsein reingestrolled und hab dann gesagt, ja so hätte ich's gern und ich hab den aller hässlichsten Blumenstrauß aller Zeiten bekommen. Also man darf da auch nicht mit so einer gewissen Lässigkeit reingehen. Nee, du musst da immer anstrengen, du musst da immer 100 Prozent gehen. Das liegt einem jetzt zu so, nee, nee, man muss da schon irgendwie auf Zack sein, auf der Höhe sein. Ist mir jetzt, glaube ich, gelungen, mittlerweile kann ich das. Und jetzt habe ich eine Masche entdeckt, Wenn ihr da draußen, ist ein bisschen jetzt so,
es wird so ein bisschen, trifft jetzt eine Mario-Bart-Gendernummer ab,
aber wenn ihr da draußen männlich seid und Single seid,
kauft Blumensträusse, ich wusste nicht, wie ich den transportieren sollte,
also hatte ich meinen Rucksack hinten auf und habe den oben reingesteckt
und mit dem Fahrrad dahin gefahren.
Da bin ich mit dem Fahrrad durch die ganze Stadt gefahren,
und oben drauf kam halt so ein riesiger Blumenstrauss, hinter meinem Kopf ist der so wie so ein Bisa-Floa herausgetreten. Und ich wurde auf dem Weg, das war 20 Minuten Fahrrad, wurde ich bestimmt achtmal angesprochen, das ist kein Scherz. Echt? Ja, achtmal nur von Frauen, auch ältere Frauen, die sagen, oh, ich hätte auch keinen Sinn, aber ich wurde von sehr vielen Frauen angesprochen, auch welche in meinem Alter, die gesagt haben, oh, da wird sich aber jemand freuen oder sowas, die meisten denken halt wahrscheinlich, man hat eine Freundin, aber. Da wird sich jemand freuen und du holst eine Blume raus und sagst, ja, du. Ja, nämlich du. Zack. Ja, und du, ohne Scheiß. Nice. Und kommst du so mit acht Frauen wieder bei deiner Wohnung an. Und dann habe ich überlegt, dann nehme ich meine Frau mit, weil ich mich mit einem Blumenschraus aufgerissen habe, und wir in meine Wohnung rein, wo alles voller Blumenstrauss ist, weil das meine Masche ist offensichtlich, aber das ist jetzt ohne Scheiß, das ist jetzt meine Masche. Ja? Ich kaufe mit dem Blumenstrauss und fahre damit durch Köln und du bist angesprochen. Einfach wie so ein Fischernetz, einfach ziehst alles mit dir hin. Es ist so interessant, weil ich wurde noch nie so oft angegrinst. Ich wurde oft angesprochen Erstmal wirst du ... Also, du wirst ... Ich wurde oft angesprochen,
aber von jedem angegrinst.
Wow.
Männer ignorieren einen komplett
und Frauen grinsen einen an.
Das ist wirklich, weil die das toll finden,
dass man Blumen hat.
Ja, stimmt, aber eigentlich ist es ...
Ja, es strahlt schon die richtigen Dinge aus.
Stimmt schon.
Ja, verdammt.
Weil ich kann kein schlechter Typ sein,
wenn ich einen Blumenstrauss in meinem Rucksack habe. Ja. Also ein Blumenstrauss sagt, du weißt, was du tust. Es ist nicht mal, genau, es ist auch nicht mal ein, die wollen dann mit mir ins Bett oder die wollen, dass ich mal mit denen ausgehe. Nein, wahrscheinlich denken die auch, dass ich eine Freundin habe und der das dann bringe, so. Ja. Ist ja wahrscheinlich auch in den meisten Fällen so. Aber es ist halt, man strahlt irgendwas aus. Man strahlt Souveränität aus. Es kann kein schlechter Kerl sein. Genau, du weißt, was du tust, du weißt, wann es sich gehört, Blumen mitzubringen, wann nicht. Das finde ich, ist eine gute Ausstrahlung. Ja, total. Das transmitiert richtige Dinge und das ist mir aufgefallen, das wäre so ein Tipp. Aber das nicht alle machen, weil dann ist es auch wie. Dann ist irgendwann immer dann so, oh. Vor allem alle mit dem gleichen Rucksack, mit dem gleichen Fahrrad durch Köln, alle durch die Gegend. Ich habe einmal, aber das war tatsächlich für ein, also da war es andersrum, da hatte ich erstes Date und erst den Damenbesuch und habe dann Blumen gekauft, weil wir davor geschrieben hatten und sie am Rande erwähnt hat, dass sie, ich weiß nicht mehr genau welches, aber eine bestimmte Blumenart mochte. Ich weiß nicht mehr welche. Es war die zweitbeliebteste nach Rose. Das ist immer so, wenn man nicht sagen will, dass man Rosen mag. Lilien. Ja, irgendwie so ein Ding. Nee, ich weiß nicht. Orchideen. Irgend so was in der Richtung. Und dann bin ich auch, dann dachte ich mir so fünf Minuten bevor sie kam, dachte ich mir, jetzt bist du mal clever. Und da habe ich noch eine von diesen Blumen gekauft, bin nach Hause gegangen und habe dann gemerkt, dass ich keine Vase hatte, aber ich dachte, das kann ich jetzt nicht wieder canceln den Plan, weil das war so romantisch in meiner Vorstellung, dass ich hier extra eine Blume gekauft habe, die ich natürlich nicht so hier bitte für dich, sondern dezent im Raum platziere, damit sie es selber findet und sich freuen kann. Und dann hatte ich aber keine Vase. Und dann dachte ich mir einfach fuck it, dann nimm einfach eine alte Mate-Glasflasche, mach da die Etiketten ab und nimm halt so eine 0,5er Pfand Mehrwegflasche als Pfand. Es ist ein Berliner Charme. Es ist so ein... Hat was. Es hat was. So Ginflaschen werden ja auch mittlerweile eine Mürre. Genau. Ja, es ist halt irgendwie so ein Recycle-Charme irgendwie. Bei dir ist es halt Cola, Cola-Dose ist halt bei dir. Beinahe war die Ginflaschen werden ja auch mittlerweile eine Mürre. Genau, ja, es ist halt irgendwie so ein Recycle-Charme irgendwie, was Urbanes. Bei dir ist es halt Cola, Cola-Dose ist es halt bei dir, bei einer ist es halt die Ginflasche, aber auch cool, sympathisch. Es ist ein urbaner Schick, ja. Da habe ich dir reingetan, kein Wasser, kein Wasser. Ich war so, ich war so out of character. Ich war wirklich wie so ein Marsianer auf der Erde, der irgendwie null klar konnte. Der halb zugehört hat im Menschunterricht. Der irgendwie Leuten während dem Gespräch die Hand schüttelt, weil er mal gesehen hat, dass das Leute machen. Und er einfach immer wieder den Leuten die Hand schüttelt. Und so war ich auch und habe die Blume reingetan und die ist sofort eingegangen. Also wirklich nach einer Stunde oder so war die tot und war sofort hängender Kopf und kaputt. Und ich glaube, es kam eher negativ an, weil ich ihr mehr oder weniger eine Leiche ihrer Lieblingsblume vor die Füße geworfen habe. Das sterben lassen, das quasi... Nee, kam nicht gut an, kam nicht gut an. Also da warst du auf jeden Fall souveräner mit deinen Blumen. Ich bin mit einem ganz heilen Blumenstrauß durch die Welt gefahren. Toll, richtig schön.
Ich glaube, ich habe da nur einmal irgendwie zum Abi-Ball oder so,
aber das war dann auch so vorgefertigte Fliesbaden.
Aber ihr müsst auch ein Fahrrad fahren,
weil das ist auch seltsam, den Rucksack zu haben
und beide Hände frei zu haben und so die Welt zu laufen.
Das macht auch keinen Sinn.
Also es war schon perfekt.
Was ich aber auch gerne machen würde,
diese Ocean's Twelve Szene nachspielen,
wo ganz am Anfang des Films Danny Ocean plant ein romantisches Abendessen mit Tess, irgendwie heile Welt, und dann kommt ja Benedikt zu Tess und Tess sagt Danny, hey Benedikt, sagt Commodore, sagt dem Commodore, die Black Pearl legt gerade an und wir müssen den Fluch brechen. Und Johnny Depp hat dann aber schon den Blumenstrauss in der Hand für das romantische Abendessen und rennt dann und wirft dann den Blumenstrauss so auf die Strasse. In Port Royal wirft er den so auf die Strasse und das ist so ein Moment, den ich auch so gern mal machen würde, mit einem Blumenstrauss in der Hand irgendwo hinzurennen und währenddessen den Blumenstrauss auf die Strasse zu werfen. Was hat der jetzt vor? Was hat der vor? Weil selbst wenn du rennst, kannst du ja trotzdem Blumenstrauss mitnehmen. Also, der behindert dich ja jetzt nicht so sehr. Aber auch mit dem Blumenstrauss zu rennen. Ja, total. Na gut, das ist sehr eindeutig. Ich komme zu spät zum Date. Mit dem Blumenstrauss, aber dann dem Blumenstrauss weglaufen, aber weiterlaufen ist, oh, Gefahr im Anflug.
Aber das macht man nicht oder so, oder? Wenn man jemanden irgendwo trifft, dann Blumen mitnehmen, weil was soll sie dann mit den Blumen den ganzen Abend machen, so, das ist da auch, also es sei denn, kann man in Restaurants, also angenommen, du triffst dich mit jemandem zum romantischen Dinner in einem Restaurant und du bringst Blumen mit, kann man dann das in die Restaurant-Vase stellen? Die Blumen? Du sagst das so, als wir das in die Restaurant-Vase, die da so steht. Naja, oder ist... Nein. Nee? Nee. Aber was macht man dann damit? Fragen. Also erstmal macht man das auch nicht. Das habe ich, glaube ich, in einem Film mal gesehen, dass es dann hieß, haben sie eine Vase für die Blumen oder so. Bestimmt. Ich glaube, das macht man so. Kann man fragen, aber es ist auch nicht so üblich, was zu einem Date, ein Auswärtsdate mitzunehmen. Ist ja eher, wenn man eingeladen wird, nimmst du was mit. So eine Flasche Wein, Blümchen. Ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt mich im Restaurant habe, würde ich jetzt keine Blümchen mitnehmen. Nee, will ich auch nicht. Generell Blumen verschenken würde ich auch nicht machen. Also erst ganz spät, wenn es so richtig auf Beziehungen hinausläuft. Ja, das Timing ist schwierig. Schwierig. Oder halt dann spätestens zur Beerdigung. Also falls sie stirbt, unerwartet. Aber dann auch nicht bunt. Dann nicht so bunt. Nee? Aber gibt es schwarze Blumen? Nee, ne? Nein. Aber Beerdigung ist gedeckt. Also dann nicht so brillig. Dann nicht so brillante Töne, sondern erdum. Dann nicht pastellig und zwischendurch so eine Pfauenfeder. Ja, ja, ja. Das war auch weird. Beim ersten Blumenstrauß hat er die Pfauenfeder genommen mit dem Satz, sag ruhig, wenn irgendwas nicht passt. Die brennende Wunderkerze mit den Worten, also wenn es zu viel ist, sag ruhig. Genau. Die Rakete. Und ich habe sofort den Satz nicht mehr ausgesprochen zu Ende. Und ich habe schon gesagt, nee, das wäre nicht so. Aber ich dachte, so was kann schief gehen, und jemand nimmt diese Faunenfeder. What the fuck, das ist ein Blumenfluss, das ist ein Florist. Aber das fände ich wieder geil, du gehst in einen Blumenladen und sagen, machen Sie mir einen Blumenstrauß mit allem ausser Blumen. Ich will alles, was sie an Deko haben. Ich will die Feder, ich will alles, nur keine Blumen. Das fände ich wieder interessant, dass du so einen Blumenstrauß mit allem ausser Blumen. Du hast dann die Wunderkerze, du hast dann irgendwie diese komische rot-weisse Zuckerstange, wo auch kein Europäer weiß, was zur Hölle das sein soll. Aber alle mittlerweile haben und das ist auch mittlerweile so wirklich ein Thing. Niemand weiß, die sind einfach eins zu eins aus Amerika übernommen und niemand weiß, was das ist. Das stimmt schon. Gibt doch so eine Art G-Stock oder was? Es gibt doch so asiatische Emojis, wo ich auch nicht genau weiß, was das ist.
Aber die ich immer benutze, wenn ich jemand Geburtstag hat, weil die so feiermäßig aussehen. Ja, genau.
Wo sowas rauskommt.
Diese Fischlampen, ne?
Ja, oder so eine Art Walnussform, so Schälchen, wo was rauskommt, so Konfetti-artiges Zeug.
Ah, ja, genau, diese Pinatas, Pinientos.
Pequenitos.
Genau, die benutze ich immer, wenn man Geburtstag hat, ohne genau zu wissen, was es ist. Nee. Inflationell benutzt. Ich versuche diesen Golf-Emoji wieder zu etablieren. Also dieses Golfloch. So dieses Eingelocht. Also so, als wenn man irgendwas gut macht, dann den zu posten. Ich habe oft das Gefühl, dass das nicht richtig verstanden wird. Nee, nee. Ich glaube, es wird dirty verstanden. Ja, eingelocht? Ja. Sagt man das in deinen Kreisen, oder was? Die habe ich schön weggelocht, oder was? Wie du innerhalb von fünf Minuten vom Romantik-Stefan zum Schlipper-Stefan irgendwie wieder kommst. Nö, aber auch der Nubstau-Stefan ist der Schlipper-Stefan. Was weggelocht. Die habe ich weggelochtelocht. Schön weggelocht. Ich glaube, beim dritten Date wird ein Golfloch-Emoji. Beim dritten Date wird weggelocht. Der Stefan-Tietze-Fick-Tipps-Ratgeber, einfach ab jetzt im Handel, bei Klett-Kotter 14,99. Aber das war auch, das hast du gerade so als Romane Stefan interpretiert, aber der Blumenschre Stefan ist ja auch ein Ficktipp Stefan. Ja, eigentlich ist das ja der Köder. Du wirfst ja den zappelnden Wurm aus, um die ganzen, um einfach einzufangen. Um den Kescher, einfach den Kescher der Liebe. Du hast einfach den Kescher der Lust im Anschlag und bist auf Jagd. Und bist unterwegs. Ja, ich ziele und schiesse und treffe und dann wird eingelocht. Dann wird Golfloch-Emoji. Ja. Und erst die Fahne raus. Immer denkt dran, seid verantwortungsbewusst, immer erst die Fahne raus. Okay? Wir sind alle Gentlemen, erst die Fahne raus. Okay, gut. Kondomische ist egal. Mir keine Beschwerden. Wenn du so mit deinem Sohn mal später ein Aufklärungsgespräch führst und er dann so, er war unsicher, weil er nicht weiß, was du mit Fahne meinst. Ich würde meinen Sohn nur Nonsens aufklären. Wirklich nur Nonsens. Pass auf, erstes Date so, und du machst das Vater-Sohn-Gespräch, er ist so, Papa, warum muss ich mich jetzt mit dir hinsetzen? Und du sagst dann so, pass auf, bevor du einlochst, Fahne raus. Tob dich aus, Junge, aber denk dran, immer erst Fahne raus.
Wurdest du aufgeklärt eigentlich so richtig von deinen Eltern?
Nein.
Ich ein bisschen, aber oft ist es, glaube ich, schwer für Eltern das Timing zu finden, weil ich glaube, Kinder heutzutage sind mit neun schon auf Pornhub unterwegs.
Da kann man denen dann natürlich eine andere Art von Aufklärung geben, als denen zu erklären, wie es funktioniert, dann zu sagen, irgendwie eher die Dinge, die sie in Pornos vermeintlich gelernt haben, wieder gerade rücken. Vielleicht ist das die neue Form von Aufklärung, aber da war es auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen zu spät, sag ich mal, aber kann auch trotzdem noch extrem unangenehm sein. Hast du noch so reagiert wie jemand, der schon sein Weihnachtsgeschenk kennt? Ja, natürlich. Aber trotzdem was überrascht reagiert. Ja, ja, klar. Ich weiss doch nicht, wie man reagieren soll. Die Fats-Reaktion. Und die anderen so, nee, wie, was hast du gemacht? Hä? Ich weiss nicht. Ich weiss nicht genau, ich glaube, ich habe mir tatsächlich mehr Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie ich reagieren soll, als es kommt. Aber das klingt so, als hätte man schon einen Fehler gemacht. Ja. Ach so, was? Überrascht. Es ist furchtbar. Ich glaube, ich würde gerne die Art von Vater sein, die mit sadistischer Freude die Tochter oder Sohn aufklärt. So maximal unangenehm. Bei uns war es dann ganz schön, weil die Schule hat die Aufgabe eigentlich erledigt, einigermaßen souverän. Also wir wurden da gut aufgeklärt. Ja. Und dann durften alle, was ich ganz toll fand, Fragen aufschreiben, anonym, weil eigentlich geht es nur darum, Ja, das hatten wir auch, glaube ich. Ängste zu nehmen und Fragen zu beantworten und anonym Fragen aufzuschreiben und die hat dann der Lehrer beantwortet. Aber das hat der Lehrer auch, der weiss ja auch nicht alles. Ja. Ich weiß noch, einer hat gefragt, warum gibt es Homosexuelle? Und dann der Lehrer liest halt die ganze Zeit so, wie lässt man ein Kondom auf? Ist es keine schlechte Frage, aber ist es schlimm, wenn man zu spät kommt? Solche Fragen, die kann man dann einfach beantworten. Zu spät? Zu früh kommt, zu spät oder gar nicht. Am nächsten Tag. Ja, am nächsten. Wenn ich verspäte. Ne, aber es sind oft so Fragen, die sind so mit, es ist nicht schlimm, muss nicht peinlich sein, so und so leicht zu beantworten. Und dann zieht er die Frage, warum gibt es Homosexuelle? Und es ist dann... Schwierig. Keine schlechte Frage. Und dann zur Not immer mit der guten alten Gegenfrage, warum nicht? Kann man eigentlich immer, kommt man gut raus. Ja, warum denn nicht? Warum denn nicht? Ja, gut. Fragen wir mal so, hat denn hier jemand was gegen Homosexuelle? Wäre mit so einer provokanten politischen Frage. Ja. Ja, jedenfalls, da hat der Lehrer dann auch keine Antwort drauf gehabt. Auch schön dann mal die Erwachsenen struggeln zu sehen. Ja. Ich glaube, ich würde meinem Kind ziemlich viel Bullshit erzählen. Auf jeden Fall. Im allgemeinen. Alte Louis C.K. Gag ihm das Wort füruhl nicht beibringen, zum Beispiel. Finde ich nicht so schlecht. So ganz essentielle Sachen. Oder ihm einfach sagen, man kann unter Wasser atmen. Also du kannst ganz so, das wäre ein bisschen gefährlich. Du willst ja nicht umbringen. Ich will lachen, du willst ja nicht umbringen. Aber du sagst, der Himmel ist grün. Oh, das stimmt aber, da gab es mal ein Experiment von irgendjemandem, wo jemandem das Wort für blau nicht beigebracht wurde und also wo man wirklich so versucht hat, so wie Farben funktionieren im Bewusstsein irgendwie, dass wenn du Worte für Farben nicht hast, du die auch nicht wahrnehmen kannst oder anders wahrnimmst, wenn du nicht die Worte dafür hast. Das ist total abgefahren, total absurd.
Aber ich glaube das nicht so richtig, weil ich lerne oft Wörter und denke mir, ah ja, cool dafür jetzt ein Wort zu haben.
Ja.
Aber ich könnte es ja nicht schon wissen, wenn ich das Wort nicht hätte.
Ja, aber das sind wahrscheinlich dann eher so soziale Phänomene oder irgendwie so Phänomene
und nicht wirklich Dinge in der Welt oder so, ich weiß es
nicht.
Kinderrug, sehe ich ja.
Handwählen?
Handwählen. Ich sehe das ja, ohne ein Wort zu kennen.
Nee, stimmt schon.
So essentielle Sachen wie Farben oder Gerüche und so.
Ist ja jetzt bei Corona jetzt viele in Geruchssinn und Geschmackssinn verloren.
Ja, ich hatte ja, ich hatte kurzzeitig Panik, dass ich Corona habe.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aus irgendeinem Moment, weil ich bin eigentlich total null Hypochonder, aber irgendwie in dem Moment habe ich Panik bekommen und dann habe ich natürlich gegoogelt und geguckt und dann dachte ich mir nämlich erst, weil ich bin nämlich klug, dann dachte ich mir, weil ich wusste, es gibt eine Entscheidung zwischen trockenem Husten und feuchtem Husten. Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich jetzt google, dann kann ich danach meinen Husten nicht mehr objektiv einschätzen, weil ich geprimed bin von dem, was ich erfahre. Also versuche ich erst, mir die Antwort zu geben, welche Art von Husten habe ich und dann zu googeln, was Corona wäre.
Generell eine gute Idee. Erstmal aufschreiben.
Erstmal Symptome ganz objektiv aufschreiben.
Genau.
Weil wenn ich sage, hast du irgendwie so ein, finden sich deine Augen so ein bisschen zu gross an?
Ja.
Also so ein bisschen, dass die so ein bisschen, so ein Millimeter zu gross sind für deine Augenhöhen. Nee. Gar nicht? Ja. Also so ein bisschen, dass die so ein bisschen so ein Millimeter zu gross sind für deine Augenhöhen.
Gar nicht. Nee.
Hast du das Gefühl? Bist du dir sicher?
Hast du das Gefühl? Aber fühl mal deine Augen,
ob die nicht so ein bisschen
ein bisschen zu gross sind.
Perfekte Augen. Okay.
Hast du Glück gehabt? Du hast es nicht.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, meine Augen
sind zu gross oder zu klein. Dass dann so ein bisschen Spiel noch ist. Dass dann noch so ein bisschen schmatzt es manchmal, wenn es dann von links nach rechts rollt, macht es dann so es hat so ein genervtes Schmatz und nicht mal so, das sind meine Augen, das meine ich. Aber das hast du wirklich? Ich auch manche andere Sachen so ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann nicht so gut in die Hocke gehen aber ich glaube, damit kann man leben, oder? Du mit deinen Augen auch? Ja, also wie oft muss man in die Hocke gehen? Ja, wie oft muss so perfekt passende Augen haben? Naja, manchmal, man fühlt sich einfach falsch in seinem Körper manchmal, dass es so nicht so richtig zusammenpasst. Irgendwie ist es nicht so bei den MacBooks oder so, dass die, ich glaube bei irgendeiner iPhone-Werbung habe ich das gesehen, dass die, weil jedes Teil von einem iPhone hat ja einen gewissen Spielraum, wie groß es ist, von der Fabrik. Minimal, aber halt einen gewissen Spielraum. Also so dieser Ventilator, aber die Teile haben halt einen gewissen Spiel. Ja, und dass die erst, sage ich mal, zehntausend Hüllen produzieren und dann zehntausend Akkus, keine Ahnung, und dann nochmal alle einzeln analysieren und die dann nochmal genau die Teile miteinander verbinden, die perfekt zusammenpassen. Weil sonst wusste es nicht. Damit es ganz perfekt passt. Das große Akku mit dem großen Chip. Ja, obwohl es die gleichen Modelle sind. Es ist immer das gleiche Akkumodell, aber die sind unterschiedlich groß. Und ich glaube, so ist es bei Menschen auch, dass du halt vielleicht augen nicht ganz in deinen schädel passen bei wie hoch also das hat so ein bisschen spiel noch gibt kann gut sein woher weist denn die einen zelle dass sie noch zum auge wird und dann die andere zelle dass sie jetzt zum lied wird ja dna das steht alles im im handbuch vielleicht hat die zelle die kam zu früh die ein eine Zelle hat zu früh gesagt, ich bin jetzt schon Lead. Und das Auge so, fuck, fuck, fuck. Und dann hängt das ganze Auge fest. Das passiert. Das passiert bestimmt. Ich habe jetzt gehört, dass, ich wurde ein bisschen psychoanalysiert, von einem Laien. einem Löwen, einem Laien. Einen Löwen? Einen Laien. Weil es gibt nach einem Schüler von Freud, Reich, gibt es Körpertypen, die auf verschiedene Arten, Charakterarten zu schliessen sind. Zum Beispiel
gibt es halt den langen Typen,
den mit den
sogenannten Lulatsch.
Nee, der
ist tatsächlich der Schizo,
der Schizophrene,
der Körpertyp
mit sehr langen Gliedern,
wo der Körper relativ
schnell, wo der Geist relativ schnell gesagt hat, oh, Körper und Geist sind was ganz anderes. Wo der Körper sich nicht identifiziert mit dem Körper. Richtig, wo der Geist, genau, wo direkt eine, aha, okay, ich gehöre hier nicht hin in die Welt, alle sehen ein bisschen anders aus, alle haben ein bisschen andere Proportionen, Gliedmassen, ich bin ein bisschen Außenseiter, gut, aber ich bin ja nicht nur mein Körper, ich bin auch mein Geist, also es entsteht direkt im Kopf so eine Distanzierung zum Körper und dadurch entsteht so ein sehr, ähm, Mensch, der sehr im Kopf ist, der viel nachdenkt, viele Sachen overthinkt, ein typischer Floating Head, weißt du? Jemand, der eher bei sich zu Hause ist, im Kopf zu Hause ist, sehr gerne mit sich alleine ist, nachdenkt, vielleicht auch kreativ wird, whatever, aber jetzt nicht anfängt, Sport zu machen gerne oder wenig Eitelkeiten entwickelt. Was mit Basketballern? Außer Basketball, das ist halt sein Ding. Aber du, du verstehst, was ich meine, das ist die Idee von Freud. Von Reich. Reich, sorry, ich wollte es nicht dem Freud die Crayals geben. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel, es ist im Bett, die Kollegin, die dann plötzlich diesen Kurs gemacht hat dafür, hat dann auch erzählt, dass die wusste Lustigerweise nur immer, was dann der Begriff ist, also das wäre der Schizophrenie. Und im Bett wäre dieser Charakter dann sehr experimentierfreudig, weil er aber auch gar nicht das als verbundenen Akt sieht, sondern eher als, ja, auch spannend, ja, Experiment.
Das finde ich immer ganz cool, das mal jetzt auszuprobieren.
Aber es ist nie ein, also Lust und Geist sind nicht verbunden,
sondern es wäre ein geistlicher Akt als jetzt ein triebvoller Akt.
Und dadurch wäre dann eher der Partner derjenige, der dann sagt,
lass uns doch mal das und das ausprobieren, Schatz.
Und ich als mein Körpertyp würde dann eher sagen, ja, warum nicht? Ohne jetzt wahnsinnig emotional daraus zu reden. Finde ich spannend. Da gibt es ja, du wärst ja eher der kleine Kompakte, das dann mal so riss. Und mit Kompakt meinst du was genau? Keine langen Glieder. Du bist so kastenförmig, du bist so, dich kann man leicht in eine Kiste stecken. Okay. Du bist so sehr, du hast nicht lange Gliedmassen. Aha. Du hast auch keinen langen Hals. Nee, das ist okay. Ja. Okay. Du bist immer so Chris. Okay. Das wäre das dann. Kannst du ja mal gucken. Ihr könnt ja aber alle die Körpertypen nach von Freud reich.
Guckt mal, wo ihr seid. Guckt mal, wo ihr seid. Ob ihr der Lulatsch seid, ob ihr der Würfel seid, der Kasten seid. Und dann hat sie mir tatsächlich von allen Körpertypen dann die Persönlichkeitsmerkmale aufgezählt. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber ich bin alles ein bisschen.
Und dann meinte sie, ja, das spricht für deinen Charakter,
weil die Schizophrenen sagen immer, dass sie alles ein bisschen sind. Ach so, okay, es gibt dann den Allrounder, der alles ist.
Der meint alles zu sein, aber nicht alles ist.
Okay, verstehe.
Das finde ich ganz spannend. Jedenfalls ein spannender Exkurs in die Psychoanalyse.
Dachte, interessiert dich vielleicht auch als Schüler Lacan.
Habe ich noch nichts davon gehört, aber...
Gibt ja auch mehrere. Gibt ja viele Meinungen.
Ja, absolut. Das ist richtig. Hast du mal überlegt, eine Psychoanalyse zu machen? Ja, ich sag noch nicht konkret, aber irgendwie ist natürlich schon interessant irgendwie, aber noch nicht konkret. Du wärst ja schon in einem perfekten Land dafür, weil du ... Ja, na ja, aber ich glaube, man braucht schon einen gewissen Leidensdruck dafür, damit es wirklich funktioniert. Also wenn du einfach nur interessehalber hingehst, dann funktioniert es nicht so richtig, weil du schon investiert sein musst. Und deswegen glaube ich, habe ich da einfach keine ... Mir geht es zu gut. Schwerende Symptome, mir geht es zu gut, ja. Du bist so sehr mit dem rein. Naja, nicht zu 100 Prozent, natürlich glaube ich, ist niemand. Aber jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, man muss jetzt was machen. Aber ja, naja. Gut, haben wir auch uns. Wir haben ja auch uns. Wir haben uns jetzt wieder. Unsere kleine Therapiestunde. Ich habe noch was für euch, und zwar fände ich es tatsächlich mega, wenn es dieses Jahr wieder klappt, denn wir suchen wieder Komparsen. Für Staffel drei suchen wir Komparsen, und es wäre mega cool für eine, wie ich finde, sehr wichtige, sehr coole Szene, suchen wir Schüler. Und wer wären die besten Komparsen, wenn nicht ihr, liebe Podcast-Sofie-Community, deswegen finde ich es ganz toll, wenn ihr zwischen 16 und 25 Jahren alt seid und am 11. September Bock habt, in Bonn Schüler zu spielen, vom Anton-Köllisch-Gymnasium in Rinseln, dann schreibt doch bitte eine E-Mail an komparsen-at-bTF-.de komparsen-btf-series.de Aber wie Serie, nicht wie Ernst. Series. Ernst gemein. Nee, Series geschrieben, wie die Serie. Das dauert so insgesamt wahrscheinlich so fünf Stunden, eine Szene. Wenn ihr da Bock habt, Zeit habt, dann können wir da so ein kleines Communitreffen machen.
Vielleicht ist Florentin ja auch da. Ich bin auf jeden Fall da. Stefan wird da sein. Ich hoffe, dass du auch vielleicht da an dem Tag vielleicht eine Szene hast. Das wäre natürlich schön. Auf jeden Fall bin ich da. Wir können reden, ihr könnt Cars kennenlernen, ihr könnt die Leute kennenlernen, die eine Live-Flex-Serie produzieren, ein ganz tolles Team. Es ist immer ein grosses Highlight, ich treffe immer wieder Leute, die sagen, ah, ich war damals Comparse bei How to Sell irgendwie, die immer noch davon erzählen im Internet, lese ich es auch ab und zu irgendwie, ja, da habe ich ja Steffen mal getroffen und so, also das scheint ein wirklich ein Leben umwälzendes Erlebnis zu sein, mal Comparse bei How to Sell Drugs online fast sein zu dürfen, deswegen greift zu, schreibt die beste Mail eures Lebens. Genau,
ich würde mich wahnsinnig freuen, wenn wir da
so eine coole Podcast-Suppe-Gruppe zusammenbekommen,
weil es ist eine wichtige Szene. Gut, wir
sind wieder zurück, wir sind braungebrannt,
wir sind bereit für die Winterzeit, für die
schöne Weihnachtszeit, die natürlich jetzt wieder ansteht.
Ich bin sowas von bereit für Weihnachten. Absolut.
Ich merke, im Winter denke ich mir immer, der Sommer ist doch das
Geilste, wo ist der Sommer hin? Im Sommer denke ich mir,
holy shit, ich wünschte, ich würde einen dicken Anurak
tragen müssen jetzt. Herrlich, wir
freuen uns weiterhin natürlich,
Also, äh... Am Ende denke ich mir immer, der Sommer ist doch das Geilste, wo ist der Sommer hin? Im Sommer denke ich mir, holy shit, ich wünschte, ich bin einen dicken Anurag tragen müssen jetzt. Herrlich, wir freuen uns weiterhin natürlich, hören wir uns nächste Woche wieder, bis dahin haut rein, macht's gut, habt eine schöne Zeit, wir freuen uns, wieder da zu sein und... Ab jetzt geht's wieder los, regelmässig. Yay, und wir heben ab, macht's gut, ciao! Oh, brrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Woooo! It's the worst bird production.